Almost heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older, everyone's moved on, remember Twitch chat, from those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes, from long ago, made you feel, you're not alone.
Kappa Pop Champ, Bible Thump, Typing Dance Game, Forehead Swift Rage, and Fail Fish.
Warum kann ich das auswendig?
Kakona.
Made you feel, you're not alone.
Kappa Pop Champ.
Keep a Forehead.
Twitch emotes, still here is far.
Wanger Z.
Singler, dankeschön für den Sub.
From yesterday.
Yesterday.
Twitch emotes.
Dennis, danke für den Sub.
Excellent Kakona Song am Anfang.
Muss jetzt auch mal wieder sein.
Recycle Story, ich hab da noch gar nichts erzählt.
Ich hab nicht ein Wort gescheit gesagt bisher.
Wie kann das Recycle Story sein?
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Excellent, excellent.
Oder auch nicht, je nachdem.
So.
Wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Nirgendwo.
Weil wir gerade erst angefangen.
Null.
Übrigens Leute, wisst ihr was richtig Pains Champ ist?
Ich hab's ja auf Twitter geschrieben.
Ich hab beim Umzug mein N64 weggeschmissen.
Richtig, richtig, äh.
Richtig blöd gewesen.
Guck mal, 2013, wo ich hierher umgezogen bin.
Hab ich mein komplett, das ganze, ich hab ne Technikkiste gehabt.
Da war auch ein ganz alter PC und so noch drin.
Ein Pentium 2 oder so.
Ähm, den hab ich weggeschmissen.
Da war halt auch mein N64 und meine Wii drin.
Und das bereue ich ja wirklich so ein bisschen.
Ich hätte mir das nicht gemacht.
Ich hätte mir das besser aufheben sollen.
Witzigerweise die Spiele hab ich aufgehoben.
Aber die Konsolen selbst hab ich nicht aufgehoben.
Was sind denn deutsche Twitter-Trends heute wieder?
Oh je, wenn ich das schon sehe, da weiß ich, dass ich da nicht reingucken will.
Also wir haben, wir haben die üblichen, wir haben die üblichen, äh, Justice, äh, Social Justice Warrior Themen auf Twitter.
Dann haben wir Fußball.
Und wir haben Fußball.
Na geil.
Das ist ja das, was die, was die Welt gebraucht hat.
Und da hab ich ja drauf gewartet, äh.
Twitter-Trends sind so Painschamp, Alter.
Kompletter Hyper, gibt es ein Hyper-Painschamp?
Hyper-Painschamp.
Gibt's da ein Emote?
Hat irgendjemand schon mal Hyper-Painschamp gemacht?
Na, wie?
Was ist da los?
Also normalerweise auf jegliche dummen Emotes, auf die ich komme, kam schon jemand anders.
Aber Hyper-Painschamp?
Anscheinend noch gar nicht.
Ich mein, Hyper-Painschamp wär eigentlich ganz einfach, einfach, den hier in rot machen und, und, dass er wackelt.
Also im Prinzip so wie,
im Prinzip so wie Hyper-Gachi.
Kann es sein, dass Hyper-Gachi gar nicht mehr aktiviert ist bei mir?
Ach nee, Gachi Hyper heißt es bei mir. Ah, alles klar, okay.
Vielleicht heißt es ja auch Painschamp Hyper.
Ne.
Wahnsinn.
Big-Brain-Emote ausgedacht. Lass mal schnell machen.
Es ist ultra oft Impf-Krams, naja, nicht nur in den Trends, das ist halt ein Thema, was die Leute beschäftigt, ne.
Ich habe jetzt gelesen, dass irgendwo in,
ich glaube Niedersachsen oder so war das,
dass sie 2G machen wollten, auch für
Supermärkte und dann hat irgendwie ein Gericht gesagt, ein paar Tage später, nee, gibt's nicht.
Anzeige ist raus.
Huuuuh.
Hast du über die Updates gesagt?
Hast du über die Updates gehört, die Call of Duty 2.0.90 fast zerstört haben, was, hä?
Das Spiel lebt noch, das ist der vorvorletzte Teil.
Call of Duty Spiele leben immer nur ein Jahr, wenn es hoch kommt. Wie kann man Call of Duty von vor zwei Jahren zerstören?
Das ist, das ist schon zerstört.
Das hat sich selbst zerstört.
Ich habe meine Windows-Updates, oh nein, nein, habe ich nicht. Übrigens, weil ich es gerade im Chat lese, New World. Leute, ihr werdet es nicht glauben.
New World hat, wo habe ich denn?
Habe ich den überhaupt noch offen? Hier. New World hat, ähm,
einen riesen, riesen Spielerzuwachs.
Von 2000
zu 9. Nee, von 18.000, 9. Letzte Woche, wo wir geguckt haben, waren es, glaube ich, nur
100.000 und jetzt sind es 118.000. Also, die haben anscheinend irgendwelche Patches rausgebracht, um nicht zu vergessen, es ist halt Weihnachten. Das ist normal.
Guck, hier waren wir mal.
Ja, das ist halt Weihnachten. Also, im Prinzip spätestens im, spätestens im Januar, Moment, wir dürfen es nicht.
Wir müssen es nicht vergessen. Die haben es geschafft, zu droppen von einer Million auf 100.000,
ja, ungefähr, oder von 900 auf 100.000, zu droppen, in einer Zeit, wo die Leute eigentlich viel Zeit vorm Rechner verbringen und jetzt noch Ferien sind.
Also, sie haben es eigentlich geschafft, in einer Zeit zu verscheißen, in der es gar nicht wirklich möglich ist, es zu verscheißen, wenn man es nicht komplett verscheißt.
Ihr wisst, ihr wisst, wie ich meine.
Well done, ja.
Was ist deine Meinung zu JetBrains Fleet?
Ist das Fleet?
Du meinst diesen Editor von denen?
Ich finde, das ist eine gute Idee.
Es ist halt nicht auf JavaScript-Basis, es ist halt auf Java-Basis.
Also, Log4J, wir kommen.
Ne, es ist halt der JetBrains IDE-Kern als Editor mit Plugins.
Finde ich, ist eine gute Sache, weil aktuell gibt es ja auch schon ein paar coole Plugins, zum Beispiel das Rust-Plugin.
Für die JetBrains IDEs.
Aber du weißt nie genau, welche du verwenden sollst.
Aktuell hast du immer IntelliJ verwendet, wenn du nicht wusstest, was du sonst verwenden solltest.
Ich finde, das ist eine sehr gute Idee von denen.
Weil, die haben nun mal die besten IDEs.
Das Einzige, wo man sich drüber streiten kann, ist, ob vielleicht, was Frontend-Sachen angeht,
Visual Studio Code nicht angenehmer ist, dank den ganzen Plugins, die es gibt.
Aber ansonsten.
Wenn du für Go guckst, Go ist Go-Land mit Abstand das Beste.
Rider ist mit Abstand das Beste, aber auch besser als Visual Studio.
Für, ne, das glaube ich nicht.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ich glaube, da schlummert zu viel oller Kram drin herum.
Für Java, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was Java angeht.
Aber was gibt es denn sonst noch für Java IDEs?
NetBeans gibt es noch, Eclipse gibt es noch.
Was gibt es denn sonst noch?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was Java, was sind denn Java IDEs?
Was gibt es denn da so alles?
So, IntelliJ ist doch eigentlich, ja, Intelli, davon rede ich doch.
Die gibt es ja klar.
Was gibt es denn zusätzlich noch?
So, das ist auch das Beste, siehste?
Also, im Prinzip haben die wirklich, also, welche Frage?
Was versteht einer hier gekaufte Alexa Englisch?
Achso, keine Ahnung, ich habe keine.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie da alles zusammenführen.
Werden, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Ne, glaube ich nicht.
Ich denke nicht.
Übrigens, Battlefield hat auch einen riesen Spielerzuwachs.
Von 30.000, 35.000 Spieler, guckt mal hier.
Aber wisst ihr, woran das liegt?
Es ist gerade kostenlos.
Es ist kostenlos und trotzdem will es keiner spielen.
Das musst du erst mal schaffen.
Es ist kostenlos und es ist, ich habe hier mal, ich kann ja mal kurz.
Steam.
Matrix HD, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Oh, ja.
Moment mal, wie viel, war wie viel negativ?
33, oh, es ist besser geworden, Leute.
Es ist Free Weekend.
Bis morgen noch.
Es ist Free Weekend und falls irgendjemand, das am Free Weekend gespielt hat und sich gedacht hat,
das will ich kaufen, kann das jetzt kaufen für 30% billiger.
Oder er geht in einen Key Shop seiner Wahl und kauft sich Battlefield für 20 Euro.
Also, was kostet es denn gerade bei G2A?
Die machen wir mal in einem, wer weiß, ich habe keinen Bock, mit den Polen-Drecker einzufangen.
Was kostet es denn hier gerade?
Battlefield 2042.
Ah, da kostet es noch weniger als auf Steam.
Aber es gibt es teilweise noch billiger, die werden ihre Codes nicht los.
Ja, mit deiner Grafikkarte kannst du es vergessen.
Das ist vorbei.
Von wann ist es?
6?
660 TI.
Von wann ist die denn?
Das muss ja noch vor der 780 gewesen sein.
Das ist 2012 oder so.
2012?
Hey, guck mal, gut geschätzt, oder?
Das ist ja uralt.
Aber, hey, sogar die Grafikkarte kannst du heute wahrscheinlich für 800 Euro verkaufen.
Wie sieht es denn eigentlich aktuell so gerade aus?
Ne, äh.
3090.
RTX, nicht GTX, meine Güte.
Wie sieht es aktuell so aus?
Wie?
Das ist doch G-Bait, das kann nicht sein.
Das stimmt fast nicht.
Stock X.
Das stimmt fast nicht, Leute.
Das ist G-Bait.
Ach, das ist irgendeine...
Das ist irgendeine Auktionsseite, oder was?
Preis-Champ?
Ne, Preis-Champ ist, äh, dead.
Der läuft einfach nur noch, den schalte ich demnächst ab.
Ich habe keinen Bock mehr, was da dran zu machen.
Hat jetzt seinen Purpose erfüllt, oder auch nicht.
Das ist aber...
Das wäre ja fast schon normaler Preis.
Das sind eher die Preise, mit denen du hier rechnen musst.
Alter, das ist so teuer.
Wenn du dir mal überlegst, ne.
Du hast einen kompletten Rechner dafür bekommen.
Und gar keinen schlechten Rechner.
Also du hast für 2900 Euro, hast du einen ziemlichen High-End-Rechner bekommen.
Vor dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Ist eigentlich mega krass.
Habe ich das mal überlegt.
Mining-Machine.
Ach ja, das ist ja günstig.
Ein Schnapper.
Guckt mal hier.
Der Bauer Gaming-PC für 12.000 Euro.
Also so gerne ich mir die Bauer-Youtube...
Äh, sorry, die Auer.
Die Au...
Die...
Die Auer-Youtube-Videos angucke.
Ähm...
Es bringt mich aber nichts dazu, ne 12.000 Euro Rechner zu kaufen.
Ah, wir können uns aber...
Wir können uns alternativ auch das Mining-Rig kaufen.
Für, äh...
Für 22.000 Euro.
Was ist denn da drin?
Außer, dass es...
Dass da 8 drauf ist.
Ist da irgen...
Ah, ok.
Wasserkühlung.
Na gut.
Ja, pre-tested.
Aber warum ist das so teuer?
Warum ist das so teuer?
Ich mein...
Ok.
Die Grafikkarte mag dich 3.000 Euro kosten.
Ähm...
Das ist doch glaube ich noch nicht mal die beste CPU, die es aktuell gibt.
Pre-tested 5,1.
Ok.
Aber...
Nichts...
Jetzt mal...
Ansatzweise...
Ach ja, Finanzierung für 1.000 Euro im Monat.
Das ist ja...
Das ist ja auch...
Äh...
Großes Entgegenkommen.
Das ist ja krass.
Was ich für einen Rechner bezahlen würde, das mache ich davon abhängig, was das Zeug kostet, wenn ich mir einen neuen Rechner kaufen muss.
Normalerweise habe ich immer so 2.000 bis 3.000 Euro bezahlt für einen neuen Rechner.
Also wenn ich...
Wenn ich wirklich komplett...
Ähm...
Komplett gekauft habe.
Und ich habe in den letzten Jahren...
Eigentlich fast immer mehr oder weniger komplett gekauft.
Das einzige, was ich umgezogen habe, oftmals war die SSD aus dem alten, neuen Rechner.
Ich habe mir überhaupt keine Arbeit mehr gemacht, den alten Rechner auszubauen aus dem alten Gehäuse.
Ich habe das alte Gehäuse einfach genommen.
SSD raus.
1 zu 1 auf den Dachboden gestellt.
Oder getauscht hier für einen Streaming-Vorschraurechner.
Und...
Äh...
Deswegen bin ich ja auch auf diesen Fractal Design...
Deswegen bin ich ja auch auf diesen Fractal Design Gehäusen hängen geblieben.
Ich habe die letzten 3 oder 4, vielleicht sogar 5 PC-Generationen, diese Fractal Design Gehäuse.
Mittlerweile das letzte, glaube ich, das R6, was ich habe.
Ich glaube, vom R4 anfangend hatte ich alle.
Haben die irgendwie...
Ne, 7er habe ich noch nicht.
Ich habe noch einen 6er, glaube ich.
Ja.
Und ich habe es mir immer...
Die Gehäuse, die es geht.
Ich glaube, das kostet...
Das kostet das...
Gucken wir mal, das aktuelle.
117 Euro.
Und ich habe es mir auch immer mit Fenster nebendran gekauft, was total bescheuert war.
Weil...
Eigentlich sieht mein Rechner von innen ganz cool aus.
Ich habe RGB RAM.
Ich habe RGB am Lüfter.
Ich habe RGB an der Grafikkarte.
Das sieht wahrscheinlich echt ganz nice aus.
Aber ich habe dann andere Rechner direkt vor dem Fenster stehen, sodass ich nicht mal mehr reingucken kann.
Also richtig hängen geblieben.
Und ich habe damals sogar richtig, richtig Lowbrain.
Ich habe damals von Noctua sogar noch Lüfter-Modding-Platten gekauft.
Gut, ich habe es mir damals irgendwie gerechtfertigt, indem ich gesagt habe, ja, der Luftfluss wird besser.
Das heißt, die übertaktete CPU wird besser gekühlt und sowas.
Was mir damals eigentlich schon klar war, dass es kompletter Schwachsinn ist.
Wie heißen die denn?
Cooler Mod.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie diese Dinger heißen.
Ja, Chromax, genau.
Da habe ich mir noch so...
Noch so komische Platten gekauft.
Um es auf den Lüfter zu machen.
Um es auf den Lüfter zu machen, dass es cooler aussieht.
Und jetzt sieht es cool aus.
Ja.
Aber ich habe das Fenster vor dem Rechner zugestellt.
Ich kann nicht mehr mal reingucken.
Richtig, richtig Sex-Head-Time.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das für ein Glas ist.
Zumindest ist das Gehäuse nice.
Es ist sehr geräumig.
Sehr stabil.
Hat Staubfilter.
Ich würde mir übrigens kein Gehäuse machen ohne Staubfilter heutzutage holen.
Staubfilter ist das Beste, was es gibt, Leute.
Ich sage es euch.
Staubfilter ist massiv so pock...
Pogge.
Ist das.
Ohne Staubfilter geht nichts.
Ja.
Die haben es halt richtig verkackt.
Und die hier auch.
Ja.
So.
Was machen wir denn jetzt?
Übrigens wisst ihr, was ich auch letztens auf YouTube gesehen habe?
Das will ich jetzt aber nicht zeigen, weil ich weiß, dass es ein etwas kontroverses Thema ist.
Aber ich glaube, die eigentliche Sache, die daraus resultiert, ist gar nicht so kontrovers.
Und zwar, ich habe ein Video gesehen.
Da hat irgendein bayerischer Politiker, war das glaube ich, hat gemeint, sie wollen Telegram verbieten.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, wie, warum?
Also, das Unreal 5?
Welches, welches?
Ja, ich habe mir das angeguckt.
Aber du meinst ja sicherlich nicht das.
Welches meinst du?
Stellenanzeigen?
Ja, ich habe gestern schon aufgenommen.
Das will der Ministerpräsident von Sachsen.
Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung, was mit dem los ist.
Also, die wollen...
Ja, das habe ich schon gesehen.
Das habe ich gesehen.
Das ist wirklich ziemlich pock.
Wobei ich halt davon ausgehe, dass der neue Matrix-Film nichts taugen wirkt.
Ganz ehrlich, die haben alle nichts getaucht, außer der erste.
Und der erste ist, finde ich, immer noch eines der besten Filme, die es gibt.
Das habe ich bestimmt schon zehnmal geguckt oder so.
Was ist das mit Cold?
Cold?
Cold Fusion?
Nein.
Was ist da?
Naja, zumindest, zumindest, angeblich, angeblich hat irgendjemand vorgeschlagen, wir könnten doch...
Also, habe ich ein Video gesehen hier bei diesen üblichen Corona-Nachrichten, dass man Telegram sperren will.
Und das passt.
Pass mal auf, warum man Telegram sperren will, weil die Leute Hatespeaken und...
Was haben sie gesagt?
Hatespeak und Hass verbreiten in Telegram.
Da dachte ich mir so, okay, was genau bringt es da jetzt, Telegram zu sperren?
Es ist ja nicht so, als wäre Telegram einer von 580 Millionen Möglichkeiten, wie man irgendwie kommunizieren kann übers Internet.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, sorgte sicherlich nicht dafür, wenn die Leute immer radikaler drauf sind.
Da müsste es auch Twitter und alles YouTube kommen.
Du müsstest alles verbieten, ja.
Und außerdem wird es garantiert nicht dafür sorgen, also wenn jetzt angeblich Telegram dafür zuständig ist, oder verantwortlich ist, dass die Leute quasi immer radikaler werden, dann wird es, also angeblich, sagt man ja, dann wird es garantiert nicht dazu führen, wenn man denen jetzt Telegram verbietet, dass die weniger radikal werden.
Wie soll das? Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Also das Einzige, was du machen könntest, ist mit den Leuten reden.
Wobei, ich glaube...
Wobei, bei den meisten ist da auch Hopfen und Malz verloren, also mit denen kannst du auch nicht mal gescheit reden.
Aber es wird garantiert nicht dazu führen, dass man weniger radikal wird, nur weil man jetzt Telegram verbietet.
Das ist total, total hängengeblieben.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man auf die Idee kommen kann.
Gibt es eigentlich eine genaue Definition, was jetzt, was jetzt eigentlich Hatespeak ist und was nicht?
Weiß man ja gar nicht so genau.
Aber Telegram verbieten wird an dem Problem nichts ändern.
Wenn du willst, dass die Leute weniger radikal werden, dann musst du nicht Telegram verbieten, sondern du musst die Ursprünge angeben.
Und das ist in der Regel ein langwieriger Prozess.
Und wird garantiert nicht dadurch irgendwie begünstigt, dass man Telegram verbietet.
Ich frag mich, wie sie das überhaupt machen wollen, gescheit.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, es gibt ja noch genug Möglichkeiten, über das Internet zu kommunizieren, dass es gar keiner mitbekommt.
Und deswegen sagen jetzt ja auch viele so nach dem Motto, Verschlüsselung muss verboten werden, weil Verschlüsselung ist böse.
Da können die Leute ja reden miteinander oder Informationen miteinander austauschen, die man nicht...
...einsehen kann.
Das ist ganz, ganz böse.
Verschlüsselung muss weg.
Und am besten noch Klarnamen überall hin.
Das kommt raus, wenn Leute da über Sachen entscheiden und davon überhaupt keine Ahnung haben.
Telegram ist quasi ein Instant Messenger, ja?
Man könnte höchstens die Grundlagen mal anpacken, sich zu überlegen, okay, warum haten, Hass sprechen die Leute denn gerade so viel?
Und das ist ein deutlich langwieriger Prozess.
Naja.
Aber auf so Bescheid...
Wenn du auf so bescheuerte Ideen kommst, kannst du nicht alles verbieten.
Bloß, bloß, weil mal irgendwas zu was gebraucht wurde, was nicht so gut war.
Dann müsstest du alles verbieten.
Dann müsstest du auch Burger essen verbieten, weil es auch nicht gut für PepoFat-Leute wie mich.
Weil ich ewig keinen Burger mehr gefuttert habe.
Jetzt wo ich gerade dabei bin, ich sollte mal wieder einen Burger essen.
Massive Burger-Stells.
Egal.
Das geht mir ja auf den...
Oh, fuck, mein Handy ist runtergefallen.
Moment.
Oh, ich hab auch noch...
Ich muss, ich muss, ich muss euch noch was sagen.
Ich hab letztens ein Video gesehen, das wurde mir vorgeschlagen auf YouTube.
Ich hab...
Ich suche mittlerweile nicht mehr nach sowas, aber...
Das war ein Video, da ging es um...
Wie heißt das auf Englisch so schön?
Body Positivity oder so?
So nach dem Motto...
Egal wie am Arsch du bist, es ist alles in Ordnung.
Oh.
Das war...
Das war so unglaublich fail.
Ich kann's gar nicht...
Ich kann's gar nicht in Worte fassen.
Leute, ihr wisst, ich bin selbst nicht der Dünnste.
Ja.
Aber dann hattest du in diesem Video welche stehen.
Die waren, keine Ahnung, 1,50 groß.
Und haben irgendwie...
Man hat's ja nicht genau gesehen, aber keine Ahnung.
Die waren 1,50 groß und haben 300 Kilo gewogen, so nach dem Motto.
Und...
Dann haben die dann erzählt, so nach dem Motto...
Ja, ich möchte mir nicht von sozialen Normen vorschreiben lassen, wie ich auszusehen habe.
Das ist gesund.
Und das ist schön.
Und sonst was.
Hey.
Jeder...
Es soll jeder mögen, was er will.
Und ich hab auch überhaupt kein Problem damit, wenn die Leute sich schön finden.
Aber mal ganz im Ernst.
Gesund ist das garantiert nicht.
Ich rede mir doch auch nicht ein, wenn ich irgendwie eine halbe Packung...
Was auch immer Plätzchen gefuttert hab, so nach dem Motto...
Oh, ja, das war jetzt aber...
Das war jetzt aber sehr gesund.
Soll ich euch mal ehrlich sagen?
Warum ich zu dick bin?
Das liegt daran...
Nicht, weil ich sage...
Oh, sieht das geil aus.
Oder oh, ist das gesund oder so.
Ich bin zu dick, weil ich zu viel vorm Rechner sitze und zu faul bin und zu viel fresse.
Das muss man halt einfach auch mal klar benennen.
Es hat auch keinen Sinn, sich irgendwie einzureden.
Das ist alles schon okay oder sonst was.
Ich meine...
Wie sagt man so?
Erkenntnis ist der erste Weg zur Besserung.
Ja?
Ich meine...
Hey.
Ob jetzt aus der Erkenntnis...
Tatenfolgen, ich sei mal dahingestellt, so wie ich mich kenne, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber man kann sich doch nicht einreden, das wäre irgendwie alles toll.
Also es ist doch ein Unterschied zwischen, sagen wir mal so, Realität akzeptieren und Realität abstreiten.
Also dieses Video habe ich wirklich nicht nachvollziehen können.
Aber das war so ein typisches...
Das war so ein typisches Kekona-Ami-Video.
Da gibt es relativ viele in dieser Richtung.
Echt, das verstehe ich nicht.
Ganz ehrlich.
Also ich rede mir nicht ein, das wäre super, super hübsch und, und, und, äh...
Keine Ahnung, gesund oder sowas.
Das ist doch, das ist doch bescheuert.
Ich muss sagen, es ist ja auch durchaus besser geworden, seitdem ich mich mal mindestens 1 bis 1,5 oder sogar 2 Stunden am Tag normal, äh, sportlich bisschen betätige.
Jetzt nehme ich wenigstens nicht mal zu.
Und es ist jetzt bei mir auch nicht so, als wäre das ultra.
Also ich bin jetzt kein...
Ich bin ja nicht irgendwie 1,50 und wiege 200 Kilo oder so.
Aber...
Corona schlägt mir dazu.
Aber es ist schon eine ganze Ecke zu viel.
Ne, das, das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Und dann hat mir YouTube noch ein Video vorgeschlagen.
Ich weiß, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich wurde mir das zweite Video vorgeschlagen, weil ich das erste Video geguckt habe.
Ähm, das war ein Typ auf einer Feministen-Demonstration.
Und...
Also ich glaube, YouTube erkennt, wenn man Videos aus einer gewissen Ecke eben guckt, dann kriegst du noch mehr davon empfohlen.
Das war ein Typ auf einer Feministen-Demonstration mit einem Schild, genau so einem Schild, wie die anderen rumgelaufen sind.
Und dann ist er halt als einziger Mann durch diese Demonstration gelaufen und hat halt so die üblichen Dinge erzählt, die dann da erzählt wurden.
Und auf einmal geht...
Also es ging quasi in dieser Demonstration quasi um Gewalt gegen Frauen und Gewalt und das ist schlecht.
Vollkommen richtig, sehe ich auch so.
Und auf einmal kommt eine Feministin zu ihm hin und haut ihm eine runter.
Habe ich mir auch gedacht.
Geiler, geiles Beispiel für keine Gewalt.
Super, super Beispiel, super Example, ja.
Geht hin und haut ihm eine runter.
Oh Mann, also das ist wirklich voll ins eigene Bein geschossen, ja.
Echter Wahnsinn.
Er hat gar nichts gemacht.
Er ist einfach nur...
Er ist einfach nur mitgelaufen und hat gesagt, ich supporte das.
Ob er da hingegangen ist, um die wirklich zu chibäden oder nicht, kann man schlecht sagen.
Wahrscheinlich wollte er sich ein bisschen chibäden.
Aber trotzdem kann man doch nicht so blöd sein, sich so krass reizen und chibäden lassen, dass man seine komplett eigene Aussage untergräbt.
Okay, okay, ich gebe zu, es gab ja auch um Gewalt...
Es ging ja in dieser Demonstration anscheinend um Gewalt gegen Frauen, nicht um Gewalt gegen Männer.
Also Männer, ganz ruhig, eine scheuern.
Aber...
Wie bescheuert kann man eigentlich sein?
Das untergräbt quasi alles, wofür man gerade dasteht und demonstriert, wenn man dem einfach eine klatscht, um quasi um seinen Standpunkt zu untermauern.
War das bei den Amis?
Natürlich war das bei den Amis.
Wo denn sonst?
Das ist so typisch, das muss kaum noch sein.
Anders geht das gar nicht.
Natürlich war das bei den Amis.
Jetzt ging er dann auch weiter.
Es ging ja dann auch weiter.
Dann hat er gesagt, hey, was soll das hier?
Warum werde ich hier geschlagen?
Und ähm...
Dann kam dann die Nächste und hat ihm, glaube ich, eines von diesen Demo-Schildern irgendwie versucht auf den Kopf zu hauen und sowas.
Ging es richtig zur Sache.
Ich bin auch gedacht, wie bescheuert kann man dann sein?
Bei den Amis ist es ganz schlimm in der Richtung, ja.
Also...
Oh Mann.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was mit den Leuten allen los ist.
Ich finde, das ist überhaupt kein Problem, wenn jemand auch mal...
Was sagt der?
Was sagt der, dem ich nicht zustimme?
Wo ist das Problem, ja?
Ich hatte letztens auch den Ultraschwurbler unter meinen YouTube-Videos.
Der ging richtig ab.
Das habe ich euch, glaube ich, gezeigt im Stream, oder?
Der dann angefangen hat mit...
Was hat er geschrieben?
Diese...
Ich kann dieses Wort gar nicht aussprechen.
Diese infantilisierte Verächtlichmachung hier ist unerträglich oder sowas hat er geschrieben.
Das war so typisches Schwurbler-Deutsch.
Aber es ist doch kein Problem.
Ich meine, ich habe damit überhaupt keine Schmerzen, wenn einer was...
Was sagt, was ich anders sehe.
Aber...
Und das ist ja die Geschichte.
Dann sollen sich die Leute gefälligst auch nicht wundern, wenn ich was dagegen sage.
Das muss ja dann auch okay sein.
Aber ich habe überhaupt keine Probleme mit...
Wenn einer was sagt, was mir nicht gefällt.
Ich finde das sogar gut.
Ich meine, man muss sich ja nicht permanent immer zustimmen.
Aber das ist zur Zeit nicht gewollt.
Naja...
Nee, das sind keine Trolle.
Die sind davon wirklich überzeugt.
Und das Beste war...
Er hat da noch einen Link zu einem...
Schlafscharfe-Video gepostet.
Das ist ja nur wirklich so das größte...
Das größte Klischee, was es so in dieser Richtung gibt.
Jeder, der das anders sieht, automatisch schlafscharf.
Wer ist überhaupt auf dieses ultra bescheuerte Wort gekommen?
Ja...
Gut, Twitter ist das andere Extrem.
Twitter ist das andere Extrem.
Ich habe echt das Gefühl, als haben sich...
YouTube...
Wer ist denn der YouTube-Chef?
Ist das nicht...
Ist das nicht eine Chefin sogar bei YouTube?
Ist das nicht die, in der Garage sie Google gestartet haben?
Die...
Das ist doch die in der Garage, wo sie Google angefangen haben, oder?
Die Chefin von YouTube.
Also, mir kommt es echt so vor...
Als haben sich die Chefinnen und Chefs von...
Oder wie man heute so...
Heutzutage sagen kann, Chefinnen.
Also, die Chefs...
Die Chefinnen und Chefs von Facebook, YouTube und Google...
YouTube, Twitter, Facebook und so.
Als haben die sich zusammengesetzt und haben sich überlegt...
Okay, welche Verschwörungsleute und nervige Gruppen wollt ihr haben?
Und dann hat Twitter gesagt...
Ah, wir nehmen die ultrakrassen Social Justice Warrior.
YouTube hat gesagt...
Ah, wir nehmen alle Corona-Leugner.
Und Facebook hat gesagt, wir nehmen den ganzen Rest.
Auf Facebook gibt es ja einfach alles, wo du nicht möglich hältst, dass es irgendwie existiert.
Facebook ist ja so Sammelbecken für den Rest an, verrückt.
Und die ganzen Boomers, ja.
Instagram und TikTok haben die ganzen Zoomer am Start, genau.
Die Ausdruckstanz machen wollen, wenn sie Fakten über das US-Militär erzählen.
Kennt ihr dieses Video?
Ich kenne es auch noch, weil es letztens einer im Discord gepostet hat.
Irgendeine...
Versucht den Leuten zu erzählen, dass das US-Militär wohl ziemlich zur Umweltverschmutzung beiträgt.
Und das Video geht halt irgendwie fünf Minuten.
Und dass die TikTok-Zoomer aufmerksam bleiben in diesem Video,
macht sie quasi so Ausdruckstanz dabei, dass die Leute nicht weggucken.
Das ist richtig hängen geblieben.
Das ist wirklich so...
Sinnbild für aktuelle...
Aktuellen Content, äh.
Ja, genau.
Genau, das meine ich.
Boutstronic.
Oh, Mann.
Und was hat Twitch bekommen?
Twitch hat den Q-Chat bekommen.
Das muss reichen.
Die ganzen...
Die restlichen...
Irgendwie noch halbwegs normalen Leute sind auf Twitch.
Wobei man natürlich sagen muss, dass auf Twitch auch schon viele Verrückte rumlaufen.
Auf Twitch...
Ja, wen hat Twitch...
Lass mal überlegen.
Wen hat Twitch bekommen?
Das S-Wort darf man nicht mal sagen.
Das ist ja...
Das ist ja verboten.
Davon hat Twitch aber einige.
Ähm...
Was hat Twitch bekommen?
Naja, Pool-Streams.
Pool-Streams und...
Ich glaube, Twitch...
Ich glaube, auf Twitch ist, glaube ich, mehr Fanboys als überall anders.
Also, was da...
Was da teilweise abgeht...
Also, Personenkult und Fanboys ist, glaube ich, auf Twitch sogar fast noch extremer wie woanders.
Ich weiß nicht, wen Twitch abbekommen wird.
Aber ich habe den Eindruck, dass auf Twitch tatsächlich anteilmäßig noch die gescheitesten Leute sind.
Just Chatting um 3 Uhr nachts würdest du nicht als normal bezeichnen.
Ja, es gibt überall...
Was ist hier los?
Ah, ne.
Hä?
Moment, das ist genau das Gleiche, was ich hier nochmal aufhabe.
Just Chatting um 3 Uhr nachts würdest du nicht als normal bezeichnen.
Just Chatting um 3 Uhr nachts ist eine Kombination aus...
Wir sitzen halt nackig vor der Webcam.
ASMR-Videos.
Ähm...
Was ist denn sonst noch so nachts um 3?
Just Chatting.
Also, ich habe nur mitbekommen, dass letztens drei koreanische Streamerinnen gebannt wurden auf Twitch.
Weil sie sich...
Weil sie sich off-cam umziehen wollten.
Und die eine war nicht ganz off-cam genug.
Hahaha.
Selbst schuld.
Ja.
Aber ansonsten, keine Ahnung, was nachts um 3 Uhr auf Twitch abgeht.
Da bin ich selten.
Leute, ich muss noch ein bisschen mehr trinken.
Ich habe immer noch ziemlich, ziemlich...
Äh...
Vielleicht doch.
Vielleicht klinge ich ein bisschen heiser oder so.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Äh...
Mir tut immer noch der Hals weh.
So jetzt seit drei Wochen oder so schon.
Aber ich gehe in der Corona-Zeit nirgendwo zum Doktor jetzt.
War ich nicht.
Nächstes Jahr wieder.
Sackt, Alter.
Na gut.
Also.
Auf welches Video?
Ähm...
Auf das, wo ich reactet habe.
Kannst du...
Du kannst im Discord gucken.
Heiser.
Dann doch, lieber Hetzner.
Das ist eine sehr gute Überleitung.
Leute.
Bis zum Ende des Monats.
Es ist nicht mehr lange Zeit.
Könnt ihr euch noch einen 20 Euro Startguthaben...
Äh...
Gutschein mit 20 Euro Cloud-Guthaben sichern mit meinem Code.
Wenn ihr euch jetzt bei Hetzner anmeldet.
Bei Hetzner.
In der Hetzner Cloud könnt ihr 4Ms mieten.
Beziehungsweise Server mieten.
Von zu einem günstigen Preis.
Angefangen bei 4 Euro im Monat.
Inklusive IPv4-Adresse.
Deswegen ist es jetzt auch teurer geworden.
Das war mal 3 Euro.
Ähm...
Ich hoffe, sie kriegen es demnächst hin,
Server anzubieten.
Komplett ohne öffentliche IP-Adresse.
Dann könnte es nämlich nochmal eine ganze Ecke billiger sein.
Weil die meisten Server, je nachdem wie man das aufbaut,
brauchen überhaupt keine öffentliche IP-Adresse.
Jo.
Excellent.
20 Euro.
Guck mal.
Mit 20 Euro...
Wenn ihr 20 Euro Start-Guthaben könnt...
Könnt ihr schon...
Ein...
Ähm...
Hier.
Da könnt ihr die Triple-Core-Kiste fast 3 Monate betreiben.
Was gibt es da noch zu überlegen?
Dann soll ich jetzt registrieren und Easy-VM-Server sichern.
Was auch immer ihr damit anmacht, ist nicht mein Problem.
Ich will es gar nicht wissen.
Ich will es gar nicht wissen, was damit passiert.
In Norwegen.
Beste.
Excellent.
Was will man mit einem Server ohne Public-IP?
Naja, du hast vielleicht Load-Balancer davor.
Oder eine Public-IP hat.
Und hinten dran stehen 3 Server.
Die brauchen keine Public-IP.
Vor allem nicht, wenn man für die Public-IP bezahlen muss.
Für viele Anwendungen ist das sinnvoll.
Der Preis-Champ besteht auch aus einem Frontend.
Mit Load-Balancer.
Und 3 Crawler-Server.
Die Crawler-Server.
Die bräuchten nicht unbedingt Public-IP.
Könnt ihr über den Proxy rausgehen oder so.
Also ja, das gibt es schon.
Viele Anwendungszwecke.
So.
Ja.
Gut.
Gucken wir uns mal an.
Was schlägt uns denn YouTube heute vor?
Passt alles rot.
Ja, der Preis-Champ, der wird demnächst auch abgeschaltet.
9 Dinge, um Battlefield zu einem drastisch besseren Game zu machen.
Tja.
Schauen wir uns heute wieder Verschwörungsvideos an.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich fand eins, was er letztens gebracht hat, mega witzig.
Weiß aber nicht, inwieweit der Chat das witzig findet.
Das hier.
Ja, warte ein bisschen.
Das ist so.
Das ist so pepega Kekona, das Video.
Also mehr Kekona kannst du eigentlich nicht sein, wie der Typ in diesem Video.
Also nicht er, sondern der, der er zeigt.
Das wird nur noch von dem Typ getoppt, der erzählen wollte, dass Noahs Flut den Grand Canyon in einer Woche geformt hat.
Was verdient Fachinformatiker?
Ja, das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Das habe ich dir auch irgendwie offen.
Was verdient ein Fachinformatiker?
Welches Gehalt ohne Studium?
Als Informatiker im öffentlichen Dienst.
Ja gut, dann verdient man nix.
Was verdient ein Fachinformatiker?
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an, Leute.
Excellent.
Bam.
Welches Gehalt ohne Studium?
Als Informatiker im öffentlichen Dienst.
Aber lohnt sich das?
Das geringste Angebot war bisher 65.000 Euro jährlich.
Das größte waren 95.000.
Das ist durchaus gut, ja.
Sie fragen in welchem, wahrscheinlich München oder so.
Sie fragen in welchem Gebiet, also nicht Gebiet.
Ähm, äh, Gebiet ist das falsche Wort.
Ich meine nicht Themengebiet, ich meine Region, Region, meine ich.
Ja, also es kommt natürlich auf die Region an.
Okay.
Das geringste Angebot war bisher 65.000 Euro jährlich.
Das größte waren 85.000 oder 90.000.
Oh, das ist Tossmusik, das ist Tossmusik.
Das ist ACDC, das ist Tossmusik.
Ach nee, der singt.
Ach, der singt selbst.
Okay, das ist in Ordnung.
Ganz gut.
Ganz ehrlich, das ist nicht unbedingt jetzt so, also Sänger auf einer Bühne ist jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt so das typische Hobby eines, eines, äh, Fachinformatikers.
Also, die meisten dürften wahrscheinlich eher blasse Kellerhocker wie ich sein.
Aber, man sieht, es gibt in diesem Beruf mittlerweile alles.
Ich kann nicht von Anfang an gucken, wo, wie, wo ist der beste Satz, wo habe ich den besten Satz verpasst.
Das geringste Angebot war bisher 65.000.
Das größte war 85.000 oder 90.000.
Ich glaube, jetzt haben wir ein PAP-Critical Error.
Ein PAP-Critical Error hat er.
Ich habe gerade keine Idee, wo der herkommt.
Am Schluss ist der Fehler.
Ja, ich frage mich, ich frage mich auch, wo der herkommt.
Das ist immer schwer zu sagen.
Er hat einen Strichkomma oder so an der Füße stehen.
Einen Strichkomma.
Hallo, ich bin der Patrick.
Informatiker in Systemintegration
an der Technischen Hochschule in Deggendorf
am Institut für Angewandte Informatik
in Freiburg.
Real Sound.
Normal fange ich immer so um
8.30 Uhr oder um 9 Uhr an.
Alter, kann ich mal aufhören Postmusik zu spielen hier?
Das ist ja schrecklich.
Das kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Das ist für mich
ein bisschen die angenehmere Zeit.
Ich lösche das Wort einfach danach.
So.
Ich lösche, ach wobei, das ist ja
selbst gespielt von denen, dann ist ja okay.
Bevor ich jetzt aber
ein wenig tiefer in die Mails einsteige,
glaube ich, holen wir erstmal einen Kaffee.
Ja.
Dann, dann, ich muss einfach nur genug
labern.
Überwiegend Server- und Softwarearchitektur.
Sehr gut.
Vom Betriebssystem bis zum Framework kann ich eigentlich
alles entscheiden.
Ich plane auch die...
Typische Ein-Mann-IT-Abteilung, oder wie?
...verschiedenen Tools, die wir programmieren.
Und habe eben da
zwei Entwickler.
Mit denen ich das zusammen mache.
Probieren wir es mal bei einem Kollegen kurz.
Hallo Jonas.
Jonas, du kannst gerne eine Kamera einführen.
Er ist ein bisschen scheu.
Der Typ, der Typ irgendwie mag ich den, der ist cool.
Da sehe ich, dass das Formular jetzt einfach nicht
angezeigt wird.
Was ich jetzt mache, ist einfach das Log aufrufen.
Neustarten.
Einfach neu starten, wenn das Formular nicht läuft.
Wenn man sich ein bisschen auskennt, kann man da
einfach ein bisschen rauslesen, wo der Fehler ist.
Und das sehe ich jetzt ganz einfach.
Ich habe jetzt einen PHP-Critical-Error.
Ich sehe nichts, war am ganzen gewackelt.
Und das ist jetzt...
Okay.
PHP-Critical-Error.
Too few arguments to function.
Aha.
Hat irgendeiner Mistprogrammiert.
Der Fehler, den wir suchen.
Wir haben für dieses ReCAPTCHA ein sogenanntes Bundle installiert
in diesem Framework und dieses Bundle wirft einen Fehler.
Jonas, schaust du mal kurz
den Fehler nach, wo es das sein könnte?
Wenn du das jetzt nicht findest, dann schauen wir
miteinander noch einmal.
Danke dir.
Bis dann.
10 vor.
Dort sagen wir, fahren wir.
Ein bisschen Puffer einplanen.
Ich müsste auch noch kurz tanken.
Dienstreise.
Turnschuh-Admin.
Bester.
Großes Event ist heute der sogenannte Steuerungskreis
bei uns.
Aha.
1,53.
Das ist so krass, was das zurzeit kostet.
Das Auto, da habe ich schon immer gesagt,
dieses Auto war so mein Traumauto.
Wenn ich mir das mal leisten kann, ist alles gut.
Aber ich brauche keinen Porsche fahren.
Also ich habe auch mein Traumauto, Leute.
Ich brauche auch kein anderes.
Meine Jahresrückblick gut ankommt.
Jetzt tue ich noch kurz einchecken.
Genau.
Hallo.
Okay.
Dann darf ich starten.
Und dann, quasi mit dem technischen Teil wird sie die Webseite entwickelt.
Acht Server.
Wie jetzt macht ihr noch präsentationstellt, was ist hier los?
7000 MyTIADec User, 10.000 Mediendateien, 800.000 Datenobjekte.
Und das ist jetzt noch so ein Zukunftsprojekt.
Das ist jetzt einfach nur dieses Konzept.
Das ist so eine typische Präsentation für Leute, die keinen Plan haben.
Die kann man nämlich mit so Zahlen immer super beeindrucken.
Ja.
Wenn du zum Beispiel eine Webseite hast.
hast und sagst denen, wir haben 10.000
Aufrufe am, in der, was
weiß ich, wir hatten schon 50.000
Aufrufe, dann
denken die immer, boah,
50.000 Aufrufe, alter,
ist das geil. So,
ähm, dabei ist das je nachdem gar nicht
mal sonderlich viel, ja, und
800.000 Datenobjekte,
was, ja, also
das ist so eine typische Präsentation für Leute, die keine Ahnung haben,
aber das musst du halt manchmal machen.
Ja, vier Seiten, eine PDF, sondern es ist
jetzt einfach dieses modernere
Web-Konzept. Das ist ein Konzept, das wir
ähm, nächstes Jahr
einreihen könnten. Das wollte ein
Steuerungskreis jetzt einfach mal fragen.
Das ist der Steuerungskreis.
Ja, ja, Lust machen bei uns zu arbeiten.
Ich find das, find das geil, der Steuerungskreis
hat mal wieder keinen Plan von dem, was eigentlich abgeht,
aber das ist ja normal. Agil, danke
für den, ach, ach, ach, ach, ach, nicht Agil,
Agi, ich hab Agil gelesen
aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Agi, 25
Dank für den Prime-Sub.
Perfekt, das nehm ich mit, das war's von meiner Seite.
Dann
bis zum nächsten Mal. Oh, dieses Tischgekloppe
Träger das noch irgendjemand
dieses Tischgekloppe? Das ist so dieses nach dem
Motto, Alter, bin ich froh, dass es endlich
vorbei ist. Ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf den Scheiß hier.
Ja, ich hab keine Ahnung, um was es ging, aber
ja, ja, Anerkennung, Tischgekloppe.
Das ist, ich weiß nicht,
ich find das immer richtig stumm.
Ups, hallo?
YouTube, was jetzt? Ah,
meine Maus ist der Meinung.
Das geringste Angebot war bisher
65.000 Euro jährlich.
Die höchste waren 85.000 oder
90.000.
Ich hab jetzt einen PAP Critical Error.
Hab grad keine Idee, wo der herkommt.
Am Schluss ist der Fehler dann auf Strich gekommen,
oder so an der Felsensteuer.
Das kann durchaus sein.
Hallo, ich bin der Patrick.
Hä? Moment. Was zum?
Hä?
Warum ist das jetzt nochmal von vorne gestartet?
Spaß von meiner Seite.
Du kannst natürlich jetzt nicht erwarten,
dass du da wie bei einem Auftritt von uns
nach jedem Ding einen Applaus gibst.
Um das geht's auch gar nicht.
Und ich schau in die Gesichter, die sagen dann, hä, cool.
Ich hab mir jetzt quasi so ein bisschen die Vorabbestätigung
eingeholt, meine Ideen weiter zu verfolgen.
Servus, das ist der Uli.
Ganz ehrlich, die, was auch immer
das da für ein
Entscheidungslenkungsausschuss, wie auch immer
es denn ist, die sind wahrscheinlich froh,
wenn irgendjemand was vorstellt und was sagt,
dass sie sich selbst keine Gedanken machen müssen,
sondern einfach nur was abnicken müssen.
Meine Tastatur hat einen PAP Critical Error,
das wird's sein.
Das ist mein kleiner Bruder.
Ja, so?
Genau.
Stell ich mir das in Bayern vor,
da wird erst mal abends eine Runde Bier getrunken.
Ja.
Ich krieg über Xing oder LinkedIn
jetzt zur Zeit als Informatiker
natürlich das eine oder andere Angebot.
Und die schreiben mir auch, sie haben dies und dies gelesen.
Passiert vor die Tätigkeiten
super ins Team.
Ach, das ist zwölf Uhr mittags?
Ja gut, das ist ja noch bayerischer
als abends.
Das ist ja noch bayerischer.
Zum Mittag erst mal schön Bier.
Wir bräuchten eigentlich, guck mal,
wir haben ein französisches E-Mail.
Wir haben ein russisches E-Mail.
Eigentlich bräuchten wir noch irgendein bayerisches E-Mail.
Was ist denn so ein typisches Bayern E-Mail?
Keine Ahnung, was es da gibt.
Brezel.
Das sind der Benchmark.
Das höchste waren, glaube ich, 85.000 oder 90.000.
Was ist der Benchmark?
Das sind die Boket,
das sind die Benchmark.
Und die schreiben mir auch,
sie haben dies und das gelesen.
Okay.
Was hat vor die Tätigkeiten super ins Team?
Ob ich Bock hätte, dies und das ist der Benchmark.
Das höchste waren, glaube ich, 85.000 oder 90.000 jährlich.
Das ist viel Geld, ja.
Die vom öffentlichen Rundfunk lacht sich darüber kaputt.
Was, 85.000 ist viel Geld?
Null, ich kriege viel mehr.
Und ich muss dafür nichts machen.
Wir können jedem Leute das Geld aus der Tasche ziehen.
Haha, überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich werde bezahlt, egal, was ich mache und egal, was passiert.
Haha, ja.
Also MontanaBlack schaut sich mit seinen 8.000 Livestream-Viewern,
schaut sich, der lohnt sich das an.
Wo es Arzt verdient und ob das genug ist, diskutiert er mit seinen Followern.
Das ist schon heftig.
Das ist eine geile Idee, das hat ja noch nie irgendjemand gemacht, oder?
Was hat noch nie jemand gemacht?
Hä?
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Haha.
Komm mal einen Kronen zurück.
Zwölf stimmt so.
Ciao.
Was hat noch nie jemand gemacht?
Ey, ich meine, er arbeitet wenigstens was im Vergleich zu den anderen, die sie gezeigt haben.
Ja, erst einmal ordentliche Login-Screen, so muss das Ganze natürlich sein.
Der begrüßt mich immer, wenn ich auf dem Server bin.
Und bei rot ist die Signalfarbe, da muss man ein bisschen aufschauen,
weil wir bewegen uns da im produktiven Bereich natürlich.
Das ist sinnvoll.
Wir werden jetzt mal schauen, was das Bundle, das wir da installiert haben.
Das ist tatsächlich sinnvoll, finde ich auch sinnig,
wenn man produktive Kisten, andere Login-Prompts und andere Farben verpasst.
Ja.
Also, so blöd das klingt, weil in der perfekten Welt weiß natürlich immer jeder, auf was er sich einloggt.
Aber wir wissen alle, dass das in der Praxis nicht so ist.
Wer eine genaue Version hat, möglicherweise ist die Version einfach nicht gleich.
Man muss einfach, ich sage jetzt mal, ein Freak sein in dem, was man macht.
Man muss halt Plan haben.
Im positiven Sinne einfach versuchen, die Materie zu verstehen.
Und das kann man nicht in einem Studium lernen und auch nicht in einer Ausbildung.
Das stimmt.
Man kann in einem Studium theoretische Grundlagen lernen und auch viele Hintergründe lernen.
Ja, ich sage mal Binary Tree Inverting.
Ähm.
Aber gerade.
Aber gerade, wenn irgendwie einer anruft oder du ein Ticket bekommst und drinnen steht, was weiß ich, Anwendung XY wirft Fehler.
Das ist nichts, das, was du in der Ausbildung lernst.
Das ist auch nichts, was du in einem Studium lernst.
Das lernst du nur einfach mit ein bisschen Erfahrung.
Und du lernst auch, die erste Sache, die du lernst, dass der Typ, was der in das Ticket schreibt oder was der am Telefon erzählt hat,
in der Regel nicht das sein muss, was wirklich das Problem ist.
Ja.
Die Leute erzählen viel Zeug, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Erfinden im Zweifelsfall was dazu.
Dichten sich was dazu, weil sie denken, es wäre so.
Es hätte was damit zu tun.
Also am besten ist, wie er es gemacht hat.
Das stimmt schon.
Einfach mal selbst ins Log gucken.
Was ist denn passiert, als er sich versucht hat einzuloggen?
Was ist denn kaputt gegangen?
Weil du kannst in der Regel auf.
Ja, auf User, also auf User Reports schon mal gar nicht.
Aber auch auf von irgendwelchen Entwicklern, egal von irgendwem, kannst du dich nicht wirklich drauf verlassen.
Sich selber.
Entdecken.
Version 1.5.3.0 ist es.
Ah, jetzt ob wir es.
Was sehen wir hier?
Zack, Zack, ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Also.
Wenigstens ist das.
Was verwendet er denn da?
Jetzt sieht die Leiste unten nicht.
Also ich würde fast sagen, das ist irgendein Linux mit Piling Window Manager oder sowas.
Scherz.
Also ich erkenne es jetzt an der Stelle nicht wirklich.
Aber wie Mac sieht es auch.
Das ist ein Mac.
Das sieht überhaupt nicht aus wie ein Mac.
Der hat da oben gar nicht so seine Standard Dinger.
Ah, das ist iTerm im Fullscreen oder was?
Tmax Fullscreen iTerm.
Ne, das ist die eingebaute Splitting Funktion von iTerm.
Ja, stimmt.
Man sieht das.
Und man sieht das auch an der Schriftart.
Die Schriftart ist auch die alte Default Mac Schriftart.
Das ist nicht die neue Default Mac Schriftart.
So.
Okay.
War www typischer Ort für irgend so ein PHP Gedöns.
Composer.
Okay, das ist schon ein bisschen was Neueres.
Das ist nicht so ganz Oldschool PHP Shit.
Schon irgendwas halbwegs.
Die Excel Web Zone.
Capture.
Ah, okay.
Wie viele Hydranten sind im Bild?
Markieren sie die Ladengeschäfte von vorne?
Wie viele Brücken sehen sie und wie viele Fahrräder stehen im Fahrradständer?
Also, Capture.
Dann irgendwelche Bande.
Ich hab von PHP nicht wirklich viel Ahnung.
Symfony.
Symfony ist glaube ich mit Laravel zusammen so eines der beliebtesten PHP Dinger, oder?
So Web Framework technisch.
Ich hab keine Ahnung großartig davon.
Das müsst ihr mir jetzt sagen, falls ihr damit was macht.
Okay, PHP Unit.
Wie wollen die wirklich sagen?
Die haben Tests.
Das glaub ich erst, wenn ich sehe.
Das Package ist wahrscheinlich einfach nur drinnen und wird nicht benutzt.
Also, die haben bestimmt keine Tests.
Tests, Alter.
Pepo, hey, ja, das ist ziemlich bayerisch.
Das find ich...
Moment, ich adde das mal kurz.
Ich brauch mal kurz mein Bayern Emote.
Zack.
Muss ich mal kurz adden, wenn wir gerade dabei sind.
Ja, Symfony ist sogar ziemlich weit mit Database.
Wobei, Database Migration gab's ja schon in Ruby on Rails.
Bayern.
Das ist, das ist, das ist ganz gutes Bayern Emote, oder?
Wie findet ihr das?
Ich find das eigentlich ganz gut passend.
Das ist die selbe Version.
Tatsächlich ein bisschen eine Sackgasse.
Vielleicht finden wir aber einen Fehler hier noch nicht, da müssen wir einfach machen,
weil das ist in der IT kann das auch mal ewig lang dauern.
Genau.
Also vielleicht am Schluss ist der Fehler dann ein Strich gekommen oder so.
Aber das ist einfach Teil des Berufs.
Das kann schon sein.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, nochmal so.
Wisst ihr, was jetzt gut wär?
Ich sag's, ich sag's ja nochmal, ich sag's ja nochmal.
Wenn der Quellcode in irgendeiner Versionsverwaltung liegen würde
und man irgendeine Möglichkeit hat, eine Testkiste damit zu starten.
Sei es nur, dass es eine Docker-Container ist
oder eben wirklich eine Test-VM, die dafür gebaut ist
und man versucht diesen Fehler einfach mal nachzustellen
mit der aktuellen Version.
Gucken, ob der da ist in der Testumgebung
und danach mal schauen, okay, gehen wir mal eine Versions-Tag zurück
oder gehen wir mal ein paar Comets zurück.
Es gibt ja auch git bisect.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das schon mal verwendet hast,
jemand von euch verwendet hat.
Da kannst du in git relativ gut so, äh,
wie nennt man das?
Quasi Comet-splitten, so nach dem Motto, da ging's noch, da ging's nicht
und dann wieder dazwischen und dann findest du relativ schnell das Comet,
was es kaputt gemacht hat.
Genau, Binary Search.
Das wär natürlich jetzt sehr praktisch, aber gucken wir mal weiter.
Wenn man eine Zeit lang an einem Problem sitzt
und man findet vielleicht das Problem nicht
und man wundert sich die ganze Zeit und...
Soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Das ist auch das, was ich wirklich gerne mache.
Wenn irgendwas kaputt ist,
einfach fünf Stunden zu gucken, woran's jetzt liegt
und das wieder zu fixen.
Das mach ich gerne.
Es mag jetzt vielleicht Leute geben, die sagen,
das ist doch dumm, was macht daran Spaß?
Das mach ich gerne.
Und dann am Ende natürlich noch zwei Stunden drüber erzählen,
was man als geiles rausbekommen hat.
Ja, ähm, aber das mach ich gerne.
Das mach ich viel, viel lieber,
als irgendwelche komischen Excel-Listen durchgucken
oder irgendwelche, was weiß ich, Daily-Meetings,
Wartungsarbeiten-Runden oder irgendwelche bescheuerten Diskussionen
so nach dem Motto, welche Services können wir hierhin umziehen,
was machen wir da?
Ich mach am liebsten sowas.
Dann hat man doch irgendeinen Einfall.
Ja, jetzt geht's.
Dann ist das Problem gelöst.
Es ist schon ein tolles Gefühl.
Ja.
Ja, LOL.
LOL.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Der Typ ist wenigstens real ein Fallinformatiker.
Er sitzt vorm Rechner, probiert drei Stunden aus
und sagt dann LOL, was ist das?
Genau so.
So muss das sein.
Was war das?
Es war tatsächlich ein Part des Bundles, den wir nicht brauchen,
der halt einfach mit dabei ist.
Ah, nice.
Abhängigkeiten wurden aktualisiert und haben es kaputt gemacht.
Ja, Dependency-Management ist halt auch so ein schönes Ding.
Es ist einfach ausgeschüttet.
Er hat einfach den Fehler ausgelöst und den Part, den wir brauchen,
der funktioniert eh.
Zwei Stunden haben wir nachher gesagt.
Ja, ja, das ist völlig normal in der Web-Programmierung,
dass man einfach mal einen Pfeiler sucht.
Wie hat er das überhaupt hinbekommen?
Wie hat er das jetzt hinbekommen?
Er hat weder ein Ticket bearbeitet dafür,
noch hat er irgendwie einen Daily-Scrum dazwischen gemacht,
noch hatte er ein Kanban-Board,
noch war er sonderlich agil.
Das ist doch überhaupt nicht möglich, das Problem zu fixen.
Das geht doch gar nicht.
Das ist doch laut Safe Web 5.0 Agile Certificate 528
gar nicht möglich,
dass man da überhaupt jetzt Probleme löst.
Das geht überhaupt nicht.
Wo ist die User-Story, Leute?
Wo ist die User-Story dafür?
Ich als User möchte beim Einloggen ein fehlerfreies Formular bekommen.
Du musst erst mal die User-Story definieren,
dass du überhaupt was machen kannst.
Das kann überhaupt nicht funktionieren.
Der hätte mindestens zwei Tage Vorbereitung gebraucht,
dass er überhaupt anfangen könnte.
Er hat noch nicht mal eine Sprint-Planung gemacht.
Und das Daily-Scrum und Stand-Up hat auch gefehlt.
Und natürlich die passende Retrospektive,
um den Prozess-Workflow zu verbessern.
Ist ja okay.
Natürlich meine ich das nicht ernst.
Es gibt ja Leute, die sind immer der Meinung,
ich meine das so.
Nein, nein, natürlich meine ich das nicht ernst.
Ich finde es bescheuert,
dass mittlerweile so viel drumherum gedichtet wird
an teilweise simpelste...
Ich will nicht sagen, dass das simpel ist, was er gemacht hat.
Aber ihr wisst, wie ich es meine.
Also, dass um einfachste Sachen
so viel drumherum gedichtet wird mittlerweile.
Umso mehr gefreut man sich dann, wenn man findet...
Ja, das stimmt. Dann freut man sich danach.
... monatlich 4.070 Euro brutto.
Das entspricht in meiner Lohnsteuerklasse 1
2.500 Euro grob netto.
Ich habe hier eine...
Wie? Der kriegt weniger als ich bei vier Tagen?
Was ist denn das?
Ich habe gedacht, der kriegt 580.000 oder so,
hat er doch am Anfang erzählt.
Den müssen die mehr Geld bezahlen.
Das ist ja nichts.
Hat er nicht am Anfang...
Ach nee, der hat am Anfang erzählt,
das waren Angebote, die er bekommen hat.
Aber krass, ey.
Das ist nicht viel.
Also, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, das ist nichts.
Weil das ist nichts ist natürlich im Vergleich zu Leuten,
die vielleicht in anderen Branchen arbeiten.
Da ist das ganz schön viel immer noch.
Aber...
Also...
Dem sollten sie durchaus mehr bezahlen,
weil er macht ja auch einen wirklich kompetenten Eindruck.
Eine 40-Stunden-Woche.
Ich weiß sehr wohl von Freunden und Bekannten,
dass in der freien Wirtschaft das auch manchmal überspannt wird,
wenn da Kundenprojekte eben da sind.
Ja, das stimmt. Da hat er recht.
Das ist bei manchen so.
Gerade wenn du im Consulting-Bereich arbeitest, ist das so.
Aber bei mir ist das zum Beispiel nicht so.
Ich meine, ich mache zwar manchmal ein paar Sachen auch so,
außer der Reihe nach.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist eigentlich...
Das ist vorbei.
Vier Tage, acht Stunden...
Nee, sind gar nicht acht.
Sieben Stunden, achtundfünfzig oder so.
Dann ist das vorbei.
Was er verdient?
Ich glaube irgendwie 54.000...
Nee, 52.000 Euro oder so.
Irgendwie so.
Ja, das ist...
Also, da ist durchaus noch was nach oben.
Und die müssen dann am Wochenende fertig werden.
Am Wochenende spiele ich gerne Musik und Auftritte.
Und das würde mich dann eher nicht so glücklich machen.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich eher gedacht,
das Spiel Halo Ranked am Wochenende.
Ich mache auch.
Da können wir quasi für einen kleinen Betrag proben, monatlich.
Da haben wir quasi im oberen Stock.
Das ist quasi unser Proberaum.
Da habe ich Schlagzeug aufgebaut, Anlage nebenan.
Jetzt kommt erstmal Death Metal in die Runde.
Und die anderen sind schon drin.
Aber nee, wie wisst ihr, sie machen ja ACDC Coverband oder sowas.
Und das ist unser Studio.
Und ich würde ein bisschen sagen, unser Chill-Plotz.
Natürlich, wie es sich für die Bayern gehört.
Erstes Mal ein Bier dabei.
Na klar.
Die anderen sind nicht unser Ding.
Wir haben eine Rockband.
Was wir heute machen ist, einen neuen Song auszuarbeiten.
Ich tue meistens so Basic-Akkorde.
Und ein bisschen einen Text dazu.
Und überlege mir so eine Gesangsmelodie.
Das wäre doch cool.
Und dann zeige ich das an Jojo.
Der richtig Gitarre spielen kann.
Der macht dann Akkorde, die wieder keiner versteht.
Außer er.
Und dann ist schon ein Ziel, dass jeder richtig Spaß hat, wenn er spielen muss.
Na, kleiner Scherz.
Spaß hat.
Das heißt Spaß hat, oder?
Alles klar.
Das Lied soll übrigens White Sugar Cream heißen.
Okay.
Gut, ich nehme Nummer 1.
Ich muss sagen, ohne Scheiß, in diesem Video sind mir die Leute durchaus fast alle sympathisch.
Das ist das erste Video dieser Reihe, was wir gucken, wo das so ist.
Bei den letzten Hälften.
Bei den letzten Hälften hätte ich alle so gesagt, irgendwie sind es komische Leute.
Aber mit denen kann ich mich irgendwie identifizieren.
Dann machen wir es meistens so, dass wir das Geld, das wir einnehmen, durch sechs teilen.
Wir haben fünf Personen.
Also jeder kriegt quasi seinen Anteil.
Und die sechste Person ist die Bandkasse.
Lass mich raten, die ist leer.
Mein erster Auftritt vor Live-Publikum war unfassbar schwierig.
Ich war unfassbar glücklich danach.
Aber es war sehr schwierig.
So dieser, ich verlasse jetzt meine Komfortzone-Moment, hat immer bisher in meinem Leben zu etwas mega Positives geführt.
Auch wenn es sehr, sehr schwierig ist, die Komfortzone zu verlassen.
Das ist natürlich klar.
Wann wird es ein Hit?
Das könnte ein Hit werden.
Okay.
Ich glaube, wir haben es für heute.
Ich habe das aufgenommen.
Das Gute ist, dass ich nicht weit weg wohne.
Ach ja.
Also wenn der Kerl mir noch nicht sympathisch genug war, dann jetzt.
Das ist der Bagheera.
Hallo.
Ja.
Hallo erstmal.
Hallo.
Da ist so mein Batcave.
Wo ist die RGB? Wo sind die RGBs? Guck mal. Sogar noch hier.
Ja, ja, ja. Stell es an der Wand.
Also allein das Mikro, glaube ich, kostet 360 Euro.
Interface dazu.
Ja, muss sein.
Bestimmt nochmal 150.000 Euro.
Ja, muss sein. Bestimmt nochmal 150.000 Euro.
Dann der Kopfhörerverstärker nochmal 150 pro Box, glaube ich, 300 Euro.
Fender Telecaster, der hat, glaube ich, 1700 Euro gekostet.
Oh, krass.
Also das Musikzeug ist eigentlich das Teuerste.
Ist das O-Saft?
Ja, frisch gepresst.
Boah, geil.
Frisch gepresst? Was ist, wer macht sich denn die Arbeit?
Stellungskreis war gut.
Also heute steht für den Nebenjob nicht so viel auf dem Plan.
Ja.
Und jetzt ist ein Plugin abzudehnen.
Grundsätzlich bin ich jetzt für Homepage-Programmierung da angestellt.
Aber bei allem drumherum in der IT oder beim Troubleshooting, zum Beispiel vor allem, wenn eine Homepage kaputt ist, bin meistens halt in der Agentur ich der Einzige, der die reparieren kann.
Ich kann genau die zwei Sachen.
Okay, wahrscheinlich haben Sie sonst in der Agentur noch irgendwelche Super-Marketing-Stomks, Leute.
Musik und IT. Und deswegen mache ich jetzt Musik und IT.
Ich habe eigentlich schon meistens wirklich Bock, richtig in die Arbeit zu gehen.
Vielleicht ist das nicht am Montag so, aber am Dienstag schon.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Das liegt aber auch daran, dass er sich um die Sachen kümmern kann, auf die er Bock hat.
Wenn der jetzt seinen Tag aus der Hälfte Daily-Scrums, komischen Meetings, Runden, Sprintplanungen, Daily- und Ticketgeschiss bestehen würde, hätte er auch keinen Bock.
Musik und IT.
Nice. Ja, das war ein gutes Video.
Gut dass ihr zugeschaut habt.
Er sollte mal zumindest ein bisschen Werbung machen für den YouTube-Channel der Band oder irgendwie sowas jetzt.
Da gibt es noch etwas von einem Bulldog.
Gut dass ihr zugeschaut habt.
Hier hat es noch einen Video von einem IT-Consultant.
Und hier gibt es noch ein Video von einem IT-Beamten.
Ja, mit dem Unterschied, dass er der Einzige ist, der irgendwas gearbeitet hat.
Und vergesst das Abonnieren nicht. Bis bald.
Ich weiß noch, der Projektleiter hat irgendwelche komischen Programmierübungen gemacht den ganzen Tag.
Und der Consultant war abends im Wald und hat Bäume gefällt.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Jawohl, so sieht es aus.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an?
Zeig mal her.
Was haben wir hier Schönes zu bieten?
Wir können uns von Level Cap jibäden lassen, aber da habe ich eigentlich keinen Bock drauf.
Ultimate Tierless Battlefield Tactics, 27 Millionen, Alter, ist ja klar.
Warum wir nicht nach Aliens suchen sollen.
Exposed, das habe ich noch vor letztem Jahr, vor letzter Woche offen.
Tribulan, danke für den Sub.
Poggers.
Okay, wir lassen uns jetzt von Level Cap mal kurz jibäden.
Level Cap hier.
Ja, Battlefield, oh Gott.
Battlefield 2042 hat vor allem komischen Pinguin-Weihnachtsanhänger, den sie auf Twitter promotet haben.
Und die Leute, das muss ich euch mal zeigen, das ist so witzig.
Weil so die Diskrepanz zwischen Realität.
Und Marketing-Stonks zeigt.
Was den I, danke für den Sub.
Guck mal, die posten sowas hier.
Heaven send you a holiday card.
We have the perfect one, Battlefield.
So.
Und was meint ihr, wie die Antworten darauf sind?
Was meint ihr, wie die Antworten darauf sind?
Sagen die Leute, oh cool, eine Holiday-Karte, ja, das haben wir schon immer drauf gewartet.
Oder sagen die Leute, Dice, fix your fucking game.
Okay, das war...
Das kam jetzt erst dabei.
Gestern, als ich da reingeguckt habe, waren die Comments zum größten Teil alle negativ.
Fix your game, genau.
Davon habe ich total viel gesehen.
Fix aim assist.
I'm unhappy when I play this.
Better optimization, genau.
FPS.
Crash fixen.
Domboy, danke für den Sub.
Oh Mann, okay.
Schauen wir mal kurz weiter.
Ich bin da stehen geblieben.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Stalker 2 NFTs machen will.
Blizzard, lul weh.
Und die Leute regen sich auf.
Die Leute regen sich auf.
Wir haben das auch vor einem Monat zum Vollpreis gekauft und jetzt ist es billiger.
Aber das war eigentlich davon auszugehen, oder?
Deswegen nochmal extra dumm, wenn man sich zum Vollpreis gekauft hat.
Ich hab's mir auch zum Vollpreis gekauft.
Wobei, nee, das stimmt nicht.
Ich hatte einen Code, aber das war ein Code für den Vollpreis.
Also, nein.
Für die Gold Edition, so rum.
... themselves before buying it.
There's currently a free weekend on Steam that will last until Monday, December 20th.
Free weekend?
Free weekend.
... standard time.
A new weekly challenge is now live.
Getting 30 kills.
... standard time.
... or kill assists doing 2500 damage with explorers.
Residenz-Sleeper, Alter.
... or neutralizing 15 objectives.
PPGA 29 Challenge.
Was besseres hätten sie sich jetzt nicht überlegen können.
... dealmaker epic PP29 skin.
Also logging in during the next couple of weeks will give you the Santa's little helper player card and the arctic assassin tag.
Portal also has two new modes available.
The first is 1942 versus 2042 conquest.
Ja, will kein Mensch spielen.
... which is 64 player conquest on 1942 and 2042 maps.
The second is Attack of the Elves.
It's a 32-player infection mode.
The first team to 50 points wins.
The teams are Team Santa versus Team Elves.
It's available on 1942, Bad Company 2, Battlefield 3 and 2042 maps.
Attack of the Elves will be live until January 6th.
In our final bit of Battlefield 2042 news, Battlefield Bulletin posted their final known issues recap of 2021.
These issues are being tracked by DICE and will receive fixes early in the...
Das ist ja schön, wenn die Issues...
... wenn die Issues getrackt werden von DICE.
Die haben ja gesagt, die haben ja sogar sich dazu hinreißen zu sagen, so nach dem Motto, jeder Reddit-Post wird getrackt oder irgendwie sowas, haben sie mal erzählt.
Ganz ehrlich, mit der Geschwindigkeit, die sie da an Tag legen, ist das Game in fünf Jahren vielleicht mal spielbar.
... New Year or sooner.
They include some game settings resetting on boot, the DirectX function crash, last-gen controller input delay, mastery progression...
Warte mal, ganz ehrlich.
... for games and specialists...
Das, was bis jetzt gefixt wurde, das ist ja, sagen wir mal so, das ist Dinger, die nie hätten, auch nur ansatzweise in einem releaseden Spiel sein sollen, aber es hat nichts bisher an den grundlegenden, also an den grundlegenden Problemen, die das Spiel hat geändert, dass es eben suckt.
Dass es ein liebloses, dahin geklatschtes Stück Battlefield ist, hat keines der Updates bisher was dran geändert.
Ja, iDarkSide, das ist so.
Ich habe auch, wie gesagt, ich habe hier Urlaub seit einem Monat, seit genau einem Monat habe ich Urlaub, ja, aber ich habe auch E-Mails bekommen.
Und eine E-Mail war ganz merkwürdig, das war ein blauer Hintergrund mit Schnee drauf und weißer Schrift drauf.
Irgendjemand hat sich gedacht, das lässt sich gut lesen.
Äh, falsches Video.
... missions not tracking.
... GSC Game World found themselves in hot water after announcing NFTs for their...
Aber warum? Warum?
... upcoming Game Stalker 2.
The NFTs were intended to help fund the game's development costs with one of the NFT tokens, letting the player be an NPC in Stalker 2, assuming the token owner could make their way to the studio's office in Ukraine.
Okay, und was genau hat es jetzt mit NFTs zu tun?
Ich meine, das ist doch was, was man stinknormale Kickstarter-Belohnung machen könnte.
Was hat es denn mit...
Was hat es denn überhaupt damit zu tun, außer dass es irgendwie den aktuellen Trend mitspielt?
Also ich meine, wenn irgendjemand sich quasi das Kickstarter-Tier ersteigert hat, wäre er ein NPC in dem Spiel.
Fahr zum Entwickler hin, lass dich 3D-Modeln und lass dich in das Spiel packen.
Okay, aber was genau hat das mit NFTs zu tun?
Äh, ja, Hacky, das gibt's. Du kannst mal im Archiv gucken.
Im Archiv ist das bestimmt drin.
Wir sind übrigens gerade dabei, was heißt wir?
Äh, die BigBrainMods aus meinem Discord und hier auf Twitch sind gerade dabei, alle Worts auf YouTube hochzuladen.
Auf einem...
Extra-Channel, mit dem ich nichts zu tun habe, was auch ganz gut ist, weil falls es dort Strikes gibt, äh, ist mein Account nicht betroffen.
Richtig pfeifert.
Man könnte, man könnte auch einfach Kickstarter-Tiers machen.
Oder so wie Star Citizen das schon seit Jahren macht und irgendwie immer noch damit durchkommt, den Scheiß auf der Homepage verkaufen.
Warum auch immer das NFTs sein müssen?
Was ist denn der Vorteil davon, dass das irgendwie ein, ein, äh, ein Hashwert in einer Krypto-Blockchain oder ne, tja, was, ich, ich kann immer noch nicht genau beschreiben, was ein, was ein NFT eigentlich ist.
Gibt es irgendjemand, der wirklich griffig und kurz beschreiben kann, was ein NFT ist?
Das würde ich mal, Chat, seid mal BigBrain.
...make up for unpaid expenses.
They quickly deleted the post.
An hour later, GSC announced that they had cancelled anything NFT-related for Stalker 2.
NFTs have become a highly divisive topic, talked about in...
Das stimmt ja gar nicht.
Das stimmt doch gar nicht.
Moment.
Das wird immer gesagt, aber das stimmt doch gar nicht.
Es ist ein digitaler Gegenstand, der auch einfach nur dir gehört.
Ja, deswegen kannst du dir den Kram von Google Drive runterladen und es gibt sogar Torrents mit den, äh, mit 50 Terabyte NFT-Bildern.
Der gehört nicht nur dir.
Den kann sich jeder runterladen mittlerweile.
Zum größten Teil, ja.
NFTs, wenn du die Dinger ersteigerst, kriegst du irgendwo einen Google, Google Drive Download-Link oder sowas.
Also, es ist schwer, es ist schwer in Worte zu fassen, ja, und uns zu umreißen.
Wie ein CS-Semester mit einzigartiger Float- und Besitzer-History.
Das trifft's, für Game-Item trifft's das wahrscheinlich ganz gut.
Was ist denn ByteStrikes? Zeig her.
NFTs sind einzigartige Besitz-Zertifikate in der Blockchain, nur Besitz-Zertifikate in der Inhalt.
Ja, super.
Das bringt's halt voll, wenn sich jeder runterladen kann.
Genau, das Beispiel hab ich ja auch.
Das ist wie, wenn in einem Museum daneben, neben einem Bild eine Namensplakette hängen würde.
Aber das bedeutet nicht automatisch, dass das Bild dir in irgendeiner Art und Weise gehören würde.
Dir gehört noch nicht mal die Namensplakette.
Es ist, es ist sehr merkwürdig.
Na, zumindest, es gibt ja komplette, äh, Games und, und, äh, neue, neue Scams.
Jemand hat mal was von Earth 2 gehört?
Das ist auch so'n Ding.
Hahaha.
Scamas hoch 10.
Wo sich jetzt herausgestellt hat, bei denen ist noch nicht mal irgendwas mit NFTs.
Sondern es ist im Prinzip einfach ne stinknormale Datenbank im Hintergrund.
Aber sie tun so, als wär's krass, krass, äh, Krypto und sonst was.
Ach ja, bei Earth 2 konnte man übrigens auch das Profil der Leute mit nem Script Tag in der Profilbeschreibung kaputt machen.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen dachte man sich, es ist ne gute Idee, Script Tags zu machen.
Ja.
Um diese Script Tags nicht zu escapen.
Kein Witz.
Hahaha.
Kein, kein Witz.
Egal, gucken wir weiter.
Ja, Phil Spencer, ganz ehrlich, Phil Spencer erzählt das, was der Xbox-Marketingstrategie grad am besten in den Kram passt.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich gebe ihm in diesem Punkt recht.
Aber wir dürfen nicht davon ausgehen, dass wenn der jetzt sagt, dass das quasi schlimmes Ausnutzungszeug ist, NFTs in Spielen, dass die nicht nächsten Monat ein eigenes NFT-Game ankündigen.
Also, die, äh, ich sag mal so, der, das, das Kurzzeitgedächtnis solcher Marketing-Strongs, Leute, ist relativ kurzfristig.
Also die sagen heute, NFTs sind der Teufel und morgen kündigen sie ein eigenes NFT-Spiel an.
Nur weil das Phil Spencer heute sagt, hat das keinerlei Relevanz für die Zukunft.
When it comes to NFTs in games, are you guys for or against this type of content?
Also es ist ja nicht mal Content.
NFTs sind ja kein Content im eigentlichen Sinne.
Äh, NFTs in einem Spiel ist vielleicht höchstens, ähm, eine History, wo du gucken kannst, wem das Item mal gehört hat.
Der Content hat ja damit gar nichts zu tun.
Der Content ist ein stinknormales 3D-Model im Game, was es so, was es geben muss, unabhängig von NFTs.
Es ist ja nicht so, als wären beispielsweise das 3D-Model irgendwie in der Blockchain gespeichert oder so.
...edit once again.
This time it's trying to stop its workers from forming a union.
The gaming giant has been under extreme fire...
Wisst ihr, was das Witzige ist bei Activision Blizzard aktuell?
Da gibt es fast täglich neuen Shit, der rauskommt.
Und mittlerweile ist der Scheißhaufen schon so groß, dass wenn da jetzt einfach nur noch eine weitere Wurst oben drauf kommt, interessiert das schon gar keinen mehr.
Was macht eigentlich, wo wir gerade dabei sind, der...
...der Kurs so?
Ah!
Bobby war mal kurz, kurz vorm Rausschmiss hier, hä?
Würde ich sagen.
Hier hat er, hier hat er kurz gezittert.
Jetzt ging's wieder ein Stückchen rauf.
...multiple sexual harassment and gender-based discrimination allegations.
The most recent controversy comes after Blizzard laid off 12 contract-based quality assurance workers from Raven Studios.
Na, wer, wer braucht denn, wer braucht denn für Warzone schon bitteschön Qualität?
Und bitteschön Qualitäts- und Spieletester.
Overrated.
Man hat doch Millionen an Qualitäts- und Spieletester.
Wozu braucht man denn da eigene für?
Richtig, weg damit.
Mehr Stonks für die Aktionäre.
...by Activision Blizzard, known for working on Call of Duty Warzone.
Those 12 developers represent one third of the studio's QA team.
Activision Blizzard is converting 500 contract workers to full-time employees this year.
The layoffs at Raven are 12 of 20 contractors getting the boot across all of Activision Blizzard.
These layoffs have caused company-wide walkout protests.
A company-wide email was sent by Chief Administrative Officer Brian Beletau that asked employees to
take time to consider the consequences of your signature on unionization documents.
And of course the reaction to this email was predictable.
Take time to consider your...
Okay, das heißt, man soll sich's genau überlegen, ob man quasi...
Das ist kein Betriebsrat, das ist eine Gewerkschaft.
Also man soll sich's genau überlegen, ob man quasi... Das ist kein Betriebsrat, das ist eine Gewerkschaft.
Also man soll sich's genau überlegen, ob man quasi...
Das ist kein Betriebsrat, das ist eine Gewerkschaft.
Was es für Konsequenzen haben könnte, wenn man das unterschreibt, dass man für den Beitritt
oder die Gründung einer Gewerkschaft ist.
So.
Man könnte das jetzt ähnlich...
Man könnte das quasi in Deutschland ähnlich übersetzen zu irgendwas mit Betriebsrat,
im Endeffekt.
Es ist natürlich was anderes, aber man hat's hier beispielsweise von Amazon auch schon öfters
gehört, dass die nicht gerade happy sind, wenn die Leute das Thema Betriebsrat ansprechen.
...negative.
Oh Gott.
Der Video, den ich hier seh' – nehm' mir doch free ab wie sonst.
Da hat er irgendwas hier drauf familia.
Und damit?
Wait.
Of beer.
Das logr ich auch nie.
Dä Punkt doch.
Lass morgen noch mal.
Ok.
Ah, ich dachte, wir machen's noch weiter.....
Oh, mein Gott..
Okay, also. Moment, Corona. Also, man darf doch nicht davon ausgehen, dass die bei Blizzard jetzt die Leute einstellen, weil sie davon irgendwie überzeugt sind.
Die stellen die Leute ein, ich meine, was soll denn ein Diversity-Higher sein? So nach dem Motto, wir sind in Statistiken, haben wir zu wenig Schwarze, haben wir zu wenig Frauen, haben wir zu wenig Asiaten, haben wir zu wenig Latinos, Latinas, was auch immer.
So, was macht man jetzt? Okay, man hiret jetzt einfach welche, dass es in den Statistiken besser aussieht. Ja, geil. Das führt natürlich sicherlich dazu, dass die zugrunde liegende Kultur in diesem Unternehmen besser wird. Ganz bestimmt, ganz bestimmt.
Das ist einfach nur, ah, seht mal her, wir können in unserem Report schreiben, wir haben jetzt richtig krass Diversity, aber Menschenrechte gehen uns...
Das ist immer noch am Arsch vorbei. Das ist ja egal, aber wir haben jetzt Diversity geheiert. Das ist einfach nur, dass man wieder besser dasteht, unterm Strich. Das geht nicht darum, dass man irgendwie wirklich was ändern will da dran. Für die läuft's doch viel zu gut. Die verdienen Milliarden, warum sollen die da was dran ändern wollen? Das ist alles nur um den heißen Brei drumherum gemanagt.
In their last fiscal year, but very few of them are for executive positions.
They are being looked over for leadership roles when the company is promising to become more diverse and inclusive.
Inclusive ist nichts, was du mit Diversity hires irgendwie fördern könntest.
Inclusiveness muss von den Leuten, das muss von der Kultur ausgehen, dass du quasi Leute, wie soll ich sagen, wertschätzt, egal wer sie sind, wo sie herkommen.
Das ist eine innere...
Eigenschaft einer Unternehmenskultur.
Das ist nichts, was du mit
Wir hiren jetzt einfach viele aus Südamerika,
viele Schwarze und viele Asiaten irgendwie ändern könntest.
Weil da wird sich an der prinzipiellen
Kultur in dieser Firma nichts ändern.
Außer, dass dann eben halt
mehr Schwarze, Asiate
und Südamerikaner
schlecht behandelt werden.
Die werden ja nicht jetzt auf einmal
über Nacht zu besseren
Menschen dort im Management.
CD Projekt Red
hat sich mit vielen
Investoren verabschiedet, die über die
desaströse Eröffnung von Cyberpunk 2077
verabschiedet wurden.
Das Gesetz wurde
von Investoren verabschiedet, die
feststellten, dass sie
über das schlechte
Zustand des Spiels
auf den letzten Generationen-Konsolen
verabschiedet wurden.
Bei der Eröffnung war Cyberpunk...
Ja gut, Sony hat den Chat ja sogar aus dem Store genommen.
...nachhaltig
auf Xbox One und Playstation 4
wegen einer Liste von extensiven Bügeln
und Leistungsproblemen.
Es war so schlimm, dass Sony es tatsächlich
aus dem Playstation Store abgeholt hat und
rund 30.000
Ausgaben verabschiedet hat.
Das 1,8-Millionen-Dollar-Gesetz ist
kaum eine Ausgabe,
im Vergleich
zu den
563 Millionen,
die das Spiel
2020 durch 2020
verkauft hat.
Und nach einem VGC-Report
scheint Cyberpunk
jetzt auf
seinem zweiten Wind zu gehen,
nachdem viele der
Bugs der
Spiele
geschlossen worden sind
und weitere
Ausgaben
gearbeitet werden.
Nachdem die Fans
eine ganze
Jahrhunderte warten
für ein neues
Splinter Cell-Spiel,
hat Ubisoft
das Spiel
komplett
wieder
verbaut.
Das neue
Splinter Cell soll
doch auch
NFTs haben.
Ach nee,
Remake.
Leute,
ich sag euch,
wisst ihr,
was Splinter Cell
gebraucht hat?
Open World
und
Türme.
Ohne
Open World
und
Türme
geht
da gar
nichts.
Das Spiel wird
auch
dynamische Lichter und
Schatten
in das Spiel
integriert.
Die Hauptveränderungen
werden in Animationen
und Bewegungen
auf der ganzen Welt
sein,
um sicherzustellen,
dass es eine
Mischung
von alten
Spiele
mit den
innovativen
Szenen
in den
letzten Titeln
gibt.
Ubisoft hat
keine Spiele-Fotos
veröffentlicht
und es gibt
keine ETA
für den Start-Up.
Es hat
seit 2009
248 Millionen
Spiele
veröffentlicht
und hat
bis jetzt
148 Millionen
Spiele
mit
aktivistischen
Nutzern
pro
Monat.
Und
um
zu
feiern,
hat
YouTube
eine
Website
für
die
Kreatoren
und
Videos
gehalten,
die das Spiel
als wildes
Figur
veröffentlicht
hat.
Minecraft ist
das World of Warcraft
der heutigen
Jugend.
Quasi nicht
mal mehr
der heutigen
Jugend,
das stimmt
ja eigentlich
gar nicht.
So der
Zoomer-Generation
im Endeffekt.
Früher war
World of Warcraft
das Ultra-Hype-Game,
was jeder
gespielt hat.
So meine
Generation.
Und
Minecraft
ist
das der
30 bis
40 Generationen
oder
ja,
ist es
Warcraft,
World of Warcraft
und jetzt
die,
der generationale
ist Minecraft.
Das habe ich auch, warum eigentlich?
Weil, äh, weil die Warteschlangen so lang waren, oder?
...or register for any free trials.
The company decided to take these drastic measures following the release of the MMO's recent Endwalker expansion.
It's been so popular that the servers are still struggling to keep up with all the new players that it brought on in the two weeks after launch.
The current advertisement for Endwalker will go on.
Endwalker will go on hiatus, but Square Enix confirmed it would not suspend all marketing plans.
To help make up for the outages in pulling the game from sale, free accounts will get their playable time increased from seven days to...
Das hätte...
Das hätte Blizzard auch gerne.
Mal wieder bei einem Game.
...2021.
Before we get to our final story this week...
Warum können die nicht neue Server hinstellen?
Können sich bei Amazon auch neue Server mieten?
...to let us know what games you've been playing the most during the holiday season.
For me...
Es bringt ja nix.
Auf dem neuen Server musst du ja neue Characters erstellen und es dauert ja in Final Fantasy irgendwie 500 Stunden, bis du da auf Max-Level bist.
It's been half Battlefield 2042, half Diablo II Resurrected, which I am still addicted to, and a little bit of Townscaper, when I just need to chill.
343 Studios addressed concerns expressed by players during its Tenrai event.
The big complaint is just how much of the available event content is stuck behind a paywall...
Ja.
...being earnable through gameplay.
Ich spiele immer noch regelmäßig Halo, aber das mit dem Season Pass, also der Progress ist unglaublich langsam und das Event macht keinen Spaß.
...design Jerry Hook, some of the issues...
Die brauchen doch gar keine eigenen Server-Komponenten, die können sich doch bei Microsoft, Amazon oder Google was mieten.
...from a communication mistake.
He addressed the issues in a community stream and promised better clarity about which items are earnable and which items will be purchasable.
343 are also looking to add more event changes...
Wollen die aber nicht, dann sind sie dumm.
...so players don't feel stuck while trying to...
Wenn sie das nicht wollen, sind sie blöd. Da müssen sie halt auf Kohle verzichten.
...awards.
This is also part of an initiative that 343 has already slowly started implementing to improve the challenge system.
Since launch they've added new challenges...
Wer betreibt denn... Wollt ihr mir wirklich erzählen, Leute, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich glaub euch das jetzt einfach, Chat.
Wollt ihr mir wirklich erzählen, Final Fantasy, wer auch immer das betreibt, dahinter Infrastruktur mich, die betreiben ihre Server wirklich noch selber?
Die haben das doch garantiert bei irgendeinem Cloud-Anbieter, die haben doch da kein eigenes Rechenzentrum für.
Die könnten die Server bei Hetzner zum Beispiel betreiben.
Sollen sie... Ich kann ihnen auch einen 20-Euro-Startgutschein vermitteln.
Die haben das doch garantiert in irgendeiner Cloud laufen. Niemand hat mehr eigene Rechenzentren.
Angebunden über irgendeine Fritzbox wahrscheinlich noch, ja.
Von wie vielen Spielern reden wir? Was weiß ich, was hat Final Fantasy für Spieler?
Drei Millionen? Vier Millionen?
Fünf Millionen? Natürlich nicht gleichzeitig.
Aktive Accounts oder erstellte Accounts oder ich weiß gar nicht, wie die das machen.
Keine Ahnung. Aber es ist Sony. Ich mein, Sony hat das selbst genug.
Nee, es ist nicht Sony. Schwachsinn. Square Enix hat mit Sony nichts zu tun, oder?
Nee, nee, ist nicht Sony. Keine Ahnung.
Aber gut, dann muss man halt auf Kohle verzichten.
Das war's für diese Woche von Gaming. Wie immer, Leute, danke für's Zuschauen. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Hallo wieder.
Willkommen zurück.
Meine Damen und Herren.
Heute ist der Tag.
Ich habe meine Taktiken.
Ich habe meine Tierliste.
Und ich habe dich.
Meine loyalen Subjekte.
Mich?
Viel besser.
Heute werde ich all die interessanten Taktiken ranken, die Battlefield 2042 in einer Tierliste
haben.
Einige sind wirklich schlecht.
Einige sind wirklich gut.
Und genau wie in diesem Spiel, sind viele ziemlich enttäuscht.
Oh mein Gott.
Was heißt, viele sind enttäuscht?
Das komplette Spiel ist enttäuscht.
Aber bevor wir in die Tierliste kommen, müsst ihr euch auf meine Meinung über das Spiel
selbst interessieren.
Nun, ich denke, dass viele von uns ein Vertrauen haben.
Ja, das Spiel ist kaputt.
Das Spiel ist kaputt.
Und ja, es sollte wahrscheinlich gedelayt werden.
Aber ein berühmterter Bean Beret, wie auch du, wird das nicht als schlecht sehen.
In diesem Chaos wirst du die Möglichkeit sehen.
Du wirst Dinge sehen, die explodiert werden können.
Und heute werden wir genau das machen.
Also lasst uns beginnen.
Und wir fangen an.
Wieder einmal haben wir den langen Sniper.
Verrückt.
Letzter Video.
Diese Jungs waren am Ende der Liste.
Richtig.
Und das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ciao.
Ja, so ist richtig, Sniper Rotz.
Ist das ein Fake?
Das ist wirklich gesponsert.
Ich dachte, der will uns jetzt verarschen.
Er hat gesagt, I'm not joking.
Ja, ich dachte, das ist Meta-Joke.
Er sagt, I'm not joking, dass man besonders denkt, er jokt.
Ja, das ist wirklich gesponsert.
Ich dachte, der will uns jetzt verarschen.
Er hat gesagt, I'm not joking.
Er sagt, I'm not joking, dass man besonders denkt, er jokt.
Das ist wirklich lame.
Das ist wirklich lame in 2042.
Das bisschen, was es da in Revolution.
Und wisst ihr noch in dem Trailer, wo man gesehen hat, wie aus dem Schiff
die Wand rausfällt und alle rennen weg
und Staupen sieht übel spektakulär
aus. Und im Endeffekt gibt's das zwar
im Spiel, aber es sieht kacke aus. Genauso wie
das.
Oh.
Ja, das sieht so
schlecht aus. Guck mal.
Richtig lame.
Ja, das sieht
schon ziemlich armselig aus im Vergleich
zu BF. Hier, man muss sich
auch mal angucken, wie sehr du
Maps wie Grand Bazaar
die Wände in die Luft springen
konntest. Du konntest den Grand Bazaar zwar
nicht tragende Strukturen und die Map
richtig selbst kaputt machen, aber du konntest
den Grand Bazaar die ganzen Häuserwände
einsprengen und sowas. Das ist mehr
Zerstörung, als es auf den
meisten Battlefield 2042 Maps
insgesamt gibt.
Du musst bedenken, es ist Corona.
Oh ja, diese Begründung habe ich schon oft gehört.
Es ist Corona, auch wenn es Cheatbait ist im Chat.
Ich weiß, aber Corona ist da
keine Ausrede zu. Ich kenne das Video, wo
der Tom Henderson erzählt,
was die eigentlich für Probleme hatten. Und ja, ich kann
das auch als Entwickler oder als Programmierer nachvollziehen,
aber das Management
muss das lösen. Dafür sind die da. Dafür kriegen
die Millionen. Dafür kriegen
die ihr Geld, um so eine Scheiße zu lösen.
Und das
haben sie nicht gemacht. Weiterer Punkt, wo man es
verkackt hat.
Warum schreit der denn jetzt so?
Ja, und dann fliegt das quer über die Map.
Ja, und das funktioniert jetzt nicht im Spiel.
Weil man sich gedacht hat, ein weiterer Punkt,
den ich, der mir
wirklich, wirklich extrem
auf den Sack geht, ist dieses Gebälte-
gewesen in den Trailern, um Veteranen
und quasi ältere
Battlefield-Fans anzusprechen.
Von Dogtags
bis Rausspringen aus dem
Flugzeug und Schießen
bis zu dem Base-Jump
bis zu dem. Das war
einfach nur, um Battlefield-Veteranen
zu hypen und zum Kauf zu verleiten,
weil sie genau wussten,
wenn er erstmal rauskommt, in was
für einem Scheiß-Zustand dieses Spiel
ist, wird von diesen Spielern niemals
irgendjemand dieses Spiel kaufen.
Deswegen musste man sie gleich
catchen, die Leute, von denen man wusste,
sie bekommen nie wieder Geld von denen.
Oh, wow.
Oh, super.
Are you fucking kidding me?
It was literally in the trailer. What the fuck?
F-Tier.
Zurecht.
And for our final
F-Tier-Item. Drumroll, please.
Na, was kommt jetzt?
Hazard Zone.
In its current state.
It is just plain boring.
What is the point? Playing Hazard Zone is a
complete waste of time.
Hazard Zone ist so ein unsinniges Ding.
Das hat überhaupt keine Daseinsberechtigung in diesem Spiel.
Warum ist das überhaupt drin?
Das ist vom
Ansatz her vielleicht ein sinniger Spielmodus,
aber jetzt in der Form
ist es einfach ein
so
das ist
Hazard Zone wirkt wie ein Spielmodus,
den jemand in so einem Wochenende Modding-Competition
irgendwo erstellt hat.
Hazard Zone ist in a similar vein to games like Escape from Tarkov.
Basically, you insert it as a character of your choosing,
pick a loadout, shoot a bunch of AI,
maybe shoot the players,
extract,
and that's it.
All of it.
There's no base building,
nothing to work towards,
no special unlocks,
nothing.
Basically,
Wir haben das mal einen Nachmittag gespielt,
weil ich ein bisschen Videomaterial gebraucht habe
und es ist einfach nur
Langeweile pur.
Es sind zu wenig Spieler.
Du hast ja glaub nur nur nur nur
32 Spieler oder so.
Total wenig.
Du hast die riesengroßen Maps,
du hast komische Bots,
es passiert eigentlich nix.
Der Jeep ist OP as fuck.
Es ist einfach nur dumm, es ist unsinnig,
dass das überhaupt vorhanden ist.
Ich versteh's nicht.
There is no reason at all to play this mode.
At least in this current state.
I wanted to get a clip of us winning a game of Hazard Zone,
but I just couldn't.
Not because our aim was bad,
or our positioning was bad.
No.
We couldn't win a game of Hazard Zone,
because we couldn't fucking play one.
Ever.
Ja, das Scheiß will auch keiner mehr spielen.
Hazard Zone ist ein weiteres Beispiel dafür,
was in der Entwicklung von diesem Spiel schiefgelaufen ist.
Dass das angefangen hat,
als so eine Sorte Game dann umgewurschtelt wurde.
Wir haben's in dem Video von Tom Henderson gesehen,
wie viel da sich in der Entwicklung getan hat
und im Prinzip nur in eineinhalb Jahren
dann das restliche Spiel zusammengeschustert wurde.
Every time we queued up,
we'd get into the screen,
someone would get booted,
and then we'd return to the menu.
F-Tier.
Starting us off with D-Tier,
we have the Hacker Man, Rao.
As you can probably guess, he can hack stuff.
Ja, aber das ist total Müll.
Now, I do think there's some potential with this ability.
Das ist richtig Müll.
Ich hab's auch mal versucht, ein bisschen zu spielen.
Eigentlich find ich die Idee,
dass man einen Hacker Man im Spiel hat,
so was Richtung Sombra von Overwatch,
eigentlich ganz cool,
aber das dauert zu lang,
und es passiert kaum was,
wenn du die Dinger gehackt hast.
Ich glaub, die können nicht schießen,
oder das HUD ist disabled,
oder irgendwie sowas,
aber die Leute,
die Fahrzeuge können einfach wegfahren.
Ja.
Ja, aber das bringt nix.
Dauert viel zu lang.
Chat sagt, man bekommt nicht mal Punkte dafür.
Ja, du bekommst in diesem Spiel ja für nichts wirklich Punkte.
Du bekommst für Kills Punkte,
du bekommst für Assists, ja,
aber irgendwelche coole Aktionen gemacht,
äh, Point Stack, der hoch countet,
nö, gibt's nicht.
Und es fliegt weg.
Das ist einfach so eine heftige Enttäuschung,
das Spiel.
Jetzt, nachdem das ein Monat,
jetzt, nachdem das ein Monat raus ist,
wird mir immer mehr,
mehr klar,
an wie vielen Stellen das Spiel
eigentlich eine Enttäuschung ist.
Und was ich immer ganz grausam finde,
ist, die Leute,
das ist auch bei mir in den Kommentaren auf YouTube,
so nach dem Motto,
oh, Max,
hör doch mal auf,
das Spiel zu kritisieren,
ich hab da meinen Spaß dran,
oder irgendwie sowas.
Mein Gott, ey,
es ist doch schön,
wenn die Leute ihren Spaß dran haben.
Aber,
aber,
bin ich jetzt das Problem,
dass ich sage,
dass das Spiel Kacke ist,
oder die Leute,
die das Spiel Kacke entwickelt haben,
das ist wie,
wie wenn die Leute im Mittelalter den,
den,
den Boote erschossen haben.
Versteh das nicht.
Es gibt immer noch Leute,
die das ultra verteidigen,
als wollen sie den Fanboy Award von DICE gewinnen.
Ich sag's euch,
wie's ist.
DICE ist einfach
ein unfähiger Kackehoffen mittlerweile.
Ich zeig euch mal,
Ich bin richtig, wie sagt man so schön, salty und getriggert und getiltet und was auch immer.
Die sind so unfähig.
Ich dachte ja, es ist vorgeschoben, dass die gesagt haben vor ein paar Jahren,
die haben vor ein paar Jahren gesagt, sie können kein Bad Company 3 machen,
weil sie wissen gar nicht mehr, was Bad Company eigentlich gut gemacht hat.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, ihr labert doch bloß rum.
Fragt einfach mal ein paar Fans, spielt das alte Spiel.
Ihr kommt da schon wieder drauf.
Und außerdem ist es eh nur vorgeschoben, weil ihr aus irgendwelchen Gründen kein Bad Company 3 machen wollt.
Aber mittlerweile muss ich sagen, nein, das war die Wahrheit.
Die haben wirklich absolut keinen plassen Schimmer mehr, was Bad Company gut gemacht hat.
Und die sind auch geistig anscheinend nicht dazu in der Lage, sich rein zu versetzen,
was könnten denn die Spieler an diesem Spiel gemocht haben.
Weil wären sie in der Lage,
dann hätten sie ja auch darauf,
Sachen auf Battlefield 2042 anwenden können.
Aber sie sind nicht in der Lage.
Und ich wette mit euch, die spielen zum größten Teil ihren eigenen Scheiß nicht.
Ich habe es gesehen, ich war bei diesem einen Event dabei.
Wisst ihr, was die Leute gemacht haben?
Das ist, Leute, es ist die Wahrheit, ich kann es euch nicht beweisen.
Aber ich war bei diesem Event dabei.
Wisst ihr was?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es alle waren,
aber demjenigen von Dice, den ich im Stream,
zugeguckt habe, wisst ihr, was der gemacht hat?
Wie der Battlefield 2042 gespielt hat, das ist kein Witz.
Da stand in Orbital oben auf dem Tower und hat seine Drohne zephiert, das ganze Game.
Der hat das Spiel nicht gespielt, der hat die ganze Zeit seine Drohne zephiert.
In dem Brief You Event.
Der hat nicht gescheit gespielt.
Ah!
Die spielen das Spiel nicht, die wissen nicht, was das Spiel ausmacht, was es gut macht.
Was die alten Spiele gut gemacht haben.
Die haben keinen Plan mehr.
Anders kann man sich das auch nicht erklären.
Und dazu kommt EA noch, was es sicherlich nicht besser gemacht hat.
And be kind of funny.
DT.
ATV1.
Und die haben, die haben sicherlich, die haben sicherlich Leute, die da noch ein bisschen Gespür für haben und die dann auch noch ein bisschen Ahnung davon haben, wie man ein gutes Battlefield machen könnte.
100 pro haben die noch.
Aber auf die hört man nicht.
Und ich sage nicht mal, dass EA nicht auf die hört.
Nein.
Auch schon die oberen Führungsleute bei DICE werden da nicht drauf hören.
Das, was dort entschieden wird und gemacht wird, geht komplett an dem vorbei, was die Spieler sich wünschen von einem Battlefield.
Und ja, du kannst nicht, da bin ich der Erste, der das auch zugibt, du kannst nicht bei jedem Scheiß auf die Spieler hören.
90% der Spieler sind Kacke und Sacken in dem Game oder in jedem Spiel.
Wenn du auf die hörst, wird das Spiel schlechter.
Das ist aber auch die Aufgabe als, sagen wir mal so.
Design Director und was auch immer, da gute, gute Sachen rauszufiltern und auch ein bisschen das Gespür dafür zu haben.
Okay, Feedback von den Leuten hat Hand und Fuß und das andere ist einfach nur Rumgeheule.
Dafür ist ja so ein, sagen wir mal so, Design Typ und Regisseur und was auch immer noch alles gibt, ist ja dafür da.
Aber dann kriegen die das nicht gebacken.
Dabei wäre das, dabei wäre das gar nicht so schwierig gewesen.
Wenn man wirklich hätte wissen wollen, wie das Spiel ankommt.
Du hättest ohne Probleme Battlefield-Leute gefunden, die gut in dem Spiel sind, die quasi auch kostenlos wahrscheinlich sogar bereit gewesen wären,
Stunden in dieses Spiel in der Entwicklung zu stecken und da jetzt sinnvolles Feedback zu geben.
Kostenlos wahrscheinlich sogar, das hätten die Leute freiwillig gemacht.
Man hätte auch gute Spieler aus anderen Spielen einladen können und sagen, hey, was sagt ihr denn?
Hätten beispielsweise mal wirklich gute, nennen wir es mal Apex-Spieler, da haben sie doch, guck mal, da haben sie doch um die Ecke, haben sie doch Apex am Start.
Gute Apex-Spieler, gute PUBG-Spieler, gute Warzone-Spieler, hätten die doch mal einladen können und sagen, hey Leute, wir haben da so einen neuen Modus designt,
Hazard Zone oder Work in Progress, ein neuer Modus, der sich ein bisschen an solche Spiele anlehnt, spielt mal eine Woche und gebt uns Feedback.
Ehrliches, ehrliches Feedback.
Und dann wäre als Feedback rausgesprungen, dieser Modus ist Bullshit.
Wäre dann rausgekommen.
Aber haben sie nicht gemacht.
Sie haben sich entweder eingeredet, so nach dem Motto, oh, ist ja alles super, das Beste, was wir je entwickelt haben und oh, wir sind so proud darauf, dieses Spiel jetzt rauszuholen, oh, das ist der geilste Modus aller Zeiten.
Nee, hätten die sich mal wirklich Spieler geholt, die Ahnung haben von dem, von diesem Spiele-Genre, da wäre das Fazit gewesen, das ist einfach abgrundtiefe Krütze.
So, und das haben sie nicht gemacht.
Wahrscheinlich, weil sie sich selbst nicht eingestehen wollten, dass es Müll ist.
Und ganz ehrlich, die meisten Content-Creator, die kannst du nicht fragen, das funktioniert nicht.
Ich habe das in diesem Preview-Event erlebt, ich habe das sogar jetzt in meinem abschließenden Feedback nochmal hingeschrieben, wobei das da wahrscheinlich keinen interessieren wird.
Die meisten Content-Creator sind einfach Englischsprachigen, Englischsprachigen, Deutschen keine Ahnung, aber wahrscheinlich ist es da teilweise auch so.
Aber gerade im Englischsprachigen, das sind Arschkriecher hoch 10.
Wenn ihr mitgekriegt hättet, wie da rumgeschleimt wurde, DICE war der Meinung, sie haben das beste Spiel seit der Erfindung des Rats, seit geschnitten im Brot gemacht, nach diesem Feedback der englischsprachigen Content-Creators.
Mein Gott, haben die sich überschlagen.
Das sind solche Arschkriecher alles.
Aber gut.
Früher Infos.
Equals, mehr Views, mehr YouTube-Stonks und sonst was.
Unglaublich.
Dieses Spiel ist so versagen auf so vielen Ebenen, da fällt mir gar nichts mehr zu ein.
Ja, genau.
Ich glaube, ich habe nicht einmal ein IT-Mine geworfen in diesem Spiel.
Hat mal jemand, jetzt mal ernsthaft, wurde jemand mal von einem Repair-Tool repariert in diesem Spiel?
Jetzt mal, Hand aufs Herz, ehrlich, ehrlich.
Hat euch mal jemals einer mit, wusstet ihr, also erstens, wusstet ihr, dass das Repair-Tool überhaupt in dem Spiel ist?
Und wusstet, und wurdet ihr mal repariert, ja?
Das Spiel hat, ja, das Spiel hat ein Repair-Tool.
Glaube ich, ich habe es selbst noch nie ausgerüstet.
Big deal.
Arma-Player.
Ja.
Ganz ehrlich, ich verstehe den Sinn von Arma-Player.
Ich verstehe den Sinn von Arma-Player nicht.
Es versaut die Time-To-Kill, du weißt manchmal nicht, was Sache ist.
Dich selbst rettet es in denselben Punkten.
Und diese Wir-schieben-uns-die-Platte-rein-Animation sieht aus wie Straight aus Warzone gerippt.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Arma-Player.
Guckt mal.
Das sieht original aus wie die Amazon, äh, wie die Amazon, Alter.
Wie die Animation aus Warzone gerippt.
Oder eben aus Firestorm, da war es ja auch so.
Ja, ja, ist ja gut.
Weil Warzone Geld macht und die Leute nicht mehr in der Lage sind, eigene Spiele zu entwickeln, äh, zu entwerfen und sich zu überlegen und da was Gutes draus zu machen.
Die Leute sind einfach langweilig.
D-Tier.
Als nächstes eine nicht langweilige, lustige, aber nicht besonders effektive Strategie.
Den Feuersport des Feuers auf einem VTOL rutschen, sobald das Map startet.
Du wirst wahrscheinlich nur 10 Sekunden überleben, aber, oh mein Gott, das volle Volumen, das du schießen kannst, ist ein Zeichen, das du wirklich sehen musst.
Sobald das Spiel startet, springst du in einen VTOL mit einigen Freunden, schaust nach den Helikoptern, die die Infanterie abholen.
Wir spielen eigentlich mal einen Soundtrack, genau.
Das hat keinen Soundtrack, das hat
So ungefähr hört sich der Soundtrack an von mir.
Battlefield 2042.
Wenn ich meinen Heizlüfter im Bad anmache, weil es mich friert, das hört sich an wie der Battlefield Soundtrack.
Ja, das macht ja kein Damage, das Zeug.
Außer die Sniper.
Außer die Sniper, die irgendwie Helis two-hitten konnte oder sowas.
Ich dachte, diese Strategie wäre ziemlich gut, da vier Leute einen Tank mit AP-Runden lasern, würde sicherlich einen großen Schaden erzielen.
Warum soll ich meine Werbevideos zurücknehmen? Da kriege ich ja kein Geld.
Außerdem habe ich unterschrieben, dass ich Werbevideos mache.
Das geht nicht so einfach.
Ich habe sogar nach dem zweiten Werbevideo bei der Agentur, über die ich das gemacht habe, gefragt,
Wollt ihr wirklich, dass ich das dritte Video noch hochlade?
Und die wollten. Was soll ich denn machen?
Ich habe keine gesponserten Reviews hochgeladen von dem Spiel.
Ich habe drei Videos hochgeladen.
Ich habe ein Portal-Video hochgeladen, wo ich den Editor gezeigt habe.
Das war sogar relativ gut, das Video, unabhängig davon.
Der Rules-Editor ist auch eine coole Sache.
Man kann sich über das Spiel viel beschweren, aber das ist wirklich gut, was sie da gemacht haben.
Dann habe ich einen Gesamtüberblick hochgeladen.
So nach dem Motto, die drei Sachen gibt es.
Und dann habe ich ein Hazard Zone Video gemacht.
Ich habe keinen gesponserten Review hochgeladen.
Ich glaube doch nicht ernsthaft, dass dieses Video gesponsert war.
Also mein Review zu dem Spiel war ja im Endeffekt das hier.
Ist das noch Battlefield? Der Absturz von Battlefield?
Ich glaube doch nicht, dass das gesponsert war.
Also dann hätten die ja komplett jegliches Gehirn verloren, wenn das gesponsertes Video gewesen wäre.
Das war kein gesponsertes Video.
Natürlich nicht.
Das war gesponsert.
Hazard Zone war gesponsert.
Die Übersicht war gesponsert.
Und Portal war gesponsert.
Steht auch überall drinnen.
Der Rest nicht.
Und hier nach dem Video, wo ich das hochgeladen habe.
Hier habe ich sogar extra nochmal gefragt.
Seid ihr euch sicher?
Guck mal, das ist auch das einzige Video, was nicht mal ein Thumbnail von mir gekriegt hat.
Dass ich das wirklich hochladen soll.
Ja, und die meinten, ja, ja, mach.
Tja.
Einfach nicht annehmen.
Ja, nachher.
Das sagt sich im Nachhinein so einfach.
Woher willst du das denn wissen?
Du hast doch keine Ahnung zu dem Zeitpunkt davon.
Da dürftest du nie irgendwas annehmen.
Vor allem haben die englischsprachigen Channels sich lange sehr zurückgehalten mit Kritik zu dem Video.
Gibt es keinen Ausweg?
Doch, natürlich.
Du könntest immer noch sagen, mach ich einfach nicht.
Und am Endeffekt verklagen tut dich eh keiner.
Ob dann diese Agentur, sag mal, noch mal jemand was, jemals was mit dir macht.
Oder jemand anderes sei mal dahingestellt.
Aber ich finde es keine gute, wie soll ich sagen, Geschäftspraxis, bei irgendwas zuzusagen.
Und dann einseitig zu entscheiden, mach ich nicht.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen, wenigstens habe ich jetzt ein bisschen was mit diesem Scheißgame verdient.
Da bin ich insofern eigentlich ganz froh drüber.
Ich fand, das Spiel hat mich so viel Nerven gekostet.
Wenigstens habe ich ein bisschen Kohle gemacht damit.
Amazing, danke schön für den Sub.
Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass irgendjemand das nicht erkannt hat, dass das Werbung ist.
Aber das ist wie zu sagen, Alter, warum hat Michael Schumacher Werbung gemacht für...
Was hat denn der Werbung gemacht? Keine Ahnung.
Für Dinger.
Ballbüro. Echt?
Naja, weil sowas in der Regel, das kann ich jetzt an der Stelle vielleicht auch mal erzählen.
Ähm.
Weil sowas in der Regel gemacht wird, bevor das Spiel rauskommt.
Weil da hängt ja eine gewisse Planung und Marketingkampagne hinten dran.
Und das wird gemacht meistens Wochen, wenn nicht teilweise sogar schon Monate.
Zumindest in die Wege geleitet, bevor das Spiel eigentlich rauskommt.
Und was willst du machen im Endeffekt?
Du kannst sagen, mach ich nicht.
Wenn ich nie irgendwas mache, das ist ja nicht so, dass ich das oft machen würde allgemein.
Ich meine, wenn ich mal ein Sponsored-Video mache, das kannst du ja an einer Hand abzählen.
Sonst könntest du im Endeffekt auch gar nichts machen.
Du enabels den Hype.
Nein, ich weiß nicht, ob ich so großartig den Hype enabelt habe.
Ich meine, ob mein meistgesehenes Battlefield-Video in letzter Zeit so den Hype enabelt hat, weiß ich nicht.
Ja.
Und das hier, guck mal.
Das erste, was ich gemacht habe, war ein Video zum Release.
Erster Eindruck.
Und das war schon nicht sonderlich positiv.
Danach habe ich zwei, drei gesponsorte Videos gemacht.
Und wir müssen jetzt auch mal ehrlich sein.
Die Leute können halt auch mal gefälligst für sich denken.
Wenn ich ein Video hochlade, wo ich sage, das und das hier ist in dem Spiel drin.
Dieses Video ist gesponsert bei EA.
Also da kann ich erwarten, dass die Leute in der Lage sind, selbst zu überlegen.
Aha.
Glaube ich in einem gesponserten Video ist alles ungefragt?
Oder gucke ich mir mal beispielsweise Steam-Bewertungen oder Meta-Gruppen an?
Also irgendwas ist halt auch mal gut.
Ich kann jetzt auch nicht für alle Eventualitäten da irgendwie vorsorgen.
Also ich sehe da nichts Verwerfliches dran, wenn man klar sagt, dass das gesponsert ist, sowas zu machen.
Ansonsten müsstest du sagen, jegliches Sponsoring ist schlecht.
Aber dann hast du in der heutigen Zeit auch quasi keine hauptberuflichen Content-Creator mehr, die das machen.
Ja, das stimmt auch wieder.
Leute, selbst zu überlegen.
Aber da kann ich auch nichts.
Kann ich den Leuten auch nicht helfen.
Ey.
Es ist halt riesen Marketing-Hype, der funktioniert.
Ja, natürlich ist das so.
Aber letztendlich...
Ich bin froh, dass ich ein bisschen Kohle gemacht habe noch mit dem Game, wenn es mir so auf den Sack geht.
Wenn das Game schon nicht gut ist, habe ich wenigstens ein bisschen was dran verdient.
Zumal ich ja selbst auch gedacht habe, das kommt ja noch dabei.
Ich habe ja selbst es nicht für möglich gehalten, dass dieses Spiel so beschissen wird.
Also so ultra beschissen.
Ich habe mir vielleicht gedacht, hey, vielleicht wird das nicht...
Das allergeilste Battlefield überhaupt, ja.
Aber wer hätte denn sich im Vorfeld gedacht, dass das so beschissen wird.
So ultra beschissen.
So richtig hardcore beschissen.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Ja, da muss man halt vielleicht mal zwei Meter weit denken.
Bei einem gesponsorten Video.
Da kannst du auch sagen, ja, vielleicht haben die Leute Geld verloren.
Weil sie sich diese komischen, wie rasiere ich meinen Sack richtig Videos Werbung angucken auf YouTube.
Die gibt es ja zurzeit auch.
Weiß nicht, ob ihr die kennt.
Kennt ihr das?
Diese Men's Shaving Dings Videos, die zurzeit auch recht beliebt sind auf YouTube.
Klar, hey, vielleicht hat sich auch einer davon was gekauft, weil es beworben wurde.
Ja gut.
So, es ist halt bei Werbung so.
Kennt ihr die nicht?
Es gab ja noch bei der Beta, das war ja der Witz.
Es gab ja noch bei der Beta das Gerücht so nach dem Motto, das kommt noch das Scoreboard.
Da gibt es ja Leute, die haben das in der Beta schon verteidigt.
Die haben gesagt, Leute, Leute, das ist nur eine Beta.
Das Scoreboard kommt noch.
Aber ja, ich gebe mir insofern recht, das kann man durchaus so sehen.
Aber dann kannst du keinerlei, also dann kannst du nirgends wo mehr für irgendwas Werbung machen.
Und ich glaube, besser Kennzeichen offensichtlicher machen als ich in dem Fall, kannst du es eigentlich kaum noch.
Und dann müsstest du jegliche Werbung überall untersagen.
Kann man auch machen, kann man auch machen, ja.
Aber dann gibt es halt keinerlei professionellen E-Sport mehr.
Keinerlei professionelle Content Creator mehr.
Keinerlei professionellen Sport mehr.
Da gibt es fast nichts mehr, wenn du Werbung und Sponsoring untersagst.
Oh ja, ich fühle mich auch ultra, ultra erniedrigt durch das Scoreboard.
Ganz, ganz schrecklich, ja.
Leute, ich muss ja mal kurz was zu trinken holen.
Ich bin gleich wieder, ich bin gleich wieder am Start.
Zack.
So, wieder da.
Was das Scoreboard ist, Hate Speech.
Leute, in der heutigen Zeit kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass bei einigen das Scoreboard schon als Hate Speech durchgeht.
Weil in einem Scoreboard sieht man ja, dass Leute vielleicht besser spielen als andere.
Das geht ja auf gar keinen Fall.
So.
Gucken wir mal weiter.
Backups, you are doing them wrong.
Warum?
Ah ne, wir sind ja noch gar nicht fertig damit.
Lull.
Sekunde.
Wir haben ja die Taktik...
Wo sind wir?
Wir haben ja die Taktikliste noch gar nicht durchgeguckt.
Okay.
Only doing about one fifth of a tank's health after dumping a hundred rounds into it.
Interesting concept, but not that good.
D-Tier.
Starting us off for C-Tier.
Killing people with Backblast.
Fun fact about rocket launchers, they shoot a rocket out of this end and to propel it forwards they shoot...
Das geht?
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
...lots of hot hot gas out of this end.
As it turns out, this gas is very dangerous.
And surprisingly, Battlefield 2042 models that in-game.
So they bothered adding that little...
Anyway, we can use this knowledge...
Das ist ja nice.
...to pull off some pretty funny stuff.
In this clip, I swooped down onto this roof with a guy...
Das wusste ich nicht, ich war so scared.
...spun around 180 degrees and sent him away.
Not effective, but very funny.
C-Tier.
Now, next up, the specialist pipe.
Habt ihr das auf Twitch eigentlich mitbekommen?
Warum? Vielleicht könnt ihr mir das erklären, ich check's nicht.
Ich hab auf vielen Channels auf Twitch jetzt schon gesehen, zum größten Teil irgendwelche, sagen wir mal so ein bisschen meme-lastigere Channels,
dass die jetzt alle irgendwelche Furz-Sounds im Hintergrund haben.
Mit Channel-Commands und irgendwelchen externen Seiten, wo du donaten kannst für Furz-Geräusche und sowas.
Was ist denn da los?
Warum gibt es so viele Channels auf Twitch mittlerweile, wo es Furz-Geräusche im Hintergrund gibt?
Was ist das für ein neues Twitch-Meta?
Initially, I thought she was really good.
Perhaps even overpowered.
But, it turns out...
Ich hab gestern, das war der Höhepunkt, ich hab gestern irgendwie zwei Stunden einen Stream von einem geguckt,
der World of Warcraft Hardcore Molten Core Raid gemacht hat.
Und da hat's alle fünf Sekunden gefurzt.
Nicht deutscher Humor.
Internationale Streams.
Und wie gesagt, das war so der Höhepunkt an Furz per Minute, die ich in dem Stream gehört hab.
In anderen Streams war es ein bisschen weniger.
Aber warum ist das zurzeit auf Twitch so beliebt?
Deutschsprachige Channels guck ich kaum welche.
Keine Ahnung, ob das dort auch so ist.
Also, das ist irgendwie komisch, das neue Twitch-Meta.
She's not.
She's got this pretty neat ability, where you gain temporary wallhacks.
Ach, um wen geht's?
Ah, Pyke.
Pyke?
Puck?
Ich glaub Pyke oder so.
Ähm, ja.
Der Wallhack ist richtig sinnlos.
Am Anfang dachte man auch, oh nein, Hilfe, OP-Wallhack.
Aber es ist richtig für'n Arsch.
Zumal dich alle killen damit.
Die Leute sehen dich.
Wobei ich mir gar nicht sicher bin, ob das immer noch so ist.
Why?
I don't understand the design decision here.
The wallhack isn't even that powerful, lost like one microsecond and the enemy team
can see you in no time.
Knowing this, if you ever see this at the bottom of your screen, look at the minimap
to know exactly where the sneaky Pyke may be.
See to it.
Bot servers.
Oh, Bots.
Please.
Holy shit.
These aren't particularly exciting.
Ich mein, ein Vorteil.
Ein Vorteil haben die Bots in diesem Spiel.
Man muss das Spiel nicht länger in einem noch weniger spaßigen Zustand spielen, wie
es eh schon ist.
Also, es ist nicht so einfach.
Man muss das Spiel nicht länger in einem noch weniger spaßigen Zustand spielen, wie
es eh schon ist.
Also, es ist nicht so einfach.
Man muss das Spiel nicht länger in einem noch weniger spaßigen Zustand spielen, wie
es eh schon ist.
Also, es ist nicht so einfach.
Man muss das Spiel nicht länger in einem noch weniger spaßigen Zustand spielen, wie
es eh schon ist.
Also, es ist nicht so einfach.
Man muss das Spiel nicht länger in einem noch weniger spaßigen Zustand spielen, wie
es eh schon ist.
Also, es ist nicht so einfach.
Man muss das Spiel nicht länger in einem noch weniger spaßigen Zustand spielen, wie
es eh schon ist.
Also, es ist nicht so einfach.
Man muss das Spiel nicht länger in einem noch weniger spaßigen Zustand spielen, wie
es eh schon ist.
Also, es ist nicht so einfach.
Man muss das Spiel nicht länger in einem noch weniger spaßigen Zustand spielen, wie
es eh schon ist.
Also, es ist nicht so einfach.
Man muss das Spiel nicht länger in einem noch weniger spaßigen Zustand spielen, wie
es eh schon ist.
Our bots are completely braindead.
Ja.
Warnshotten dich manchmal.
The catch is that after 350 kills, they no longer account for anything.
But 350 kills is just about all the attachments for any gun.
I found the easiest way to kill bots was to fire up Kaleidoscope on breakthrough.
You cap the first two points and then you need to cap the flag on the skyscraper.
Das Bot ist gefixt, wirklich?
Oh.
This is more or less impossible for your team's bots to do on their own,
so you're free to go up there, run behind the elevator and throw next to these pipes.
I'm not sure why, but the enemy bots have no idea how to deal with you
and you're free to rack up as many kills as possible.
In one game of doing this, I got all of these attachments.
Pretty dumb, but you might as well take advantage of it.
C-Tier.
Next on our list, Dozer.
This guy.
He's got some good resistance that gets explosive damage
and has this, a ballistic shield.
Den Typ hab ich einmal ausgewählt und hab mir dann gedacht, nee, spielst du nicht mehr.
... the impression that the ballistic shield would be pretty shit like it is in Battlefield 4.
But...
It's actually pretty fun.
For one, you can sprint with the shield and it still pointers towards the enemy.
It can magically reflect bullets right back at people
and best of all, it's a one-hit-kill if you wax on with it.
These three things combined make sprinting at people pretty funny
and could result in you getting a few kills here and now.
Übrigens, ich hab gestern mal ein bisschen 64-Mann-Breakthrough gespielt,
das ist immer noch unspielbar.
Ganz ehrlich, 128 Spieler ist zwar ein Riesenproblem,
aber bei weitem nicht das einzige in Battlefield 2042.
Es ist im Endeffekt auch so unspielbar.
Also, kein Schimmer, was man sich dabei...
Also, ich bin's auch leid.
Ich meine, ich muss nicht alle fünf Minuten das Gleiche erzählen.
Ihr wisst ja mittlerweile, was ich über das Spiel denke.
In this clip, this guy sees me, pulls out his rocket launcher,
shoots me in the feet, I don't die because of the explosive resistance,
and then I pop him on the head.
Und jetzt in your face, bam.
See, dear.
Ich meine, guckt euch doch mal an, wie dumm diese Animation überhaupt ist.
I don't die because of the explosive resistance,
and then I pop him on the head.
Oh.
See, dear.
And finally, for our last item in C-Tier, the Tuk-Tuk.
Das Tuk-Tuk, wisst ihr, warum es das Tuk-Tuk gibt?
Wisst ihr, was der einzige Grund ist, warum das Tuk-Tuk im Spiel ist?
Der Trailer.
Genau.
Das ist der einzige Grund, warum dieses Spiel überhaupt drin ist,
äh, warum dieses Ding im Spiel ist.
Nur für den Trailer.
Playtime of this game.
I've managed to run over two people with it.
Und für den Klimaschutz, genau.
It's very weak, it's very slow, but most importantly, it's very fun.
Kennt noch jemand den, äh, das Golf-Auto aus Bad Company?
See, dear.
Gentlemen, we've arrived at B-Tier.
And to start off B-Tier, we have dog.
Robot dog.
The robot dog.
Das Ding ist auch richtig hängen geblieben.
Das Auto aimt auf 300.
Kilometer alles ab.
If you ever come across an enemy robot dog, you'd know that they are incredibly annoying.
You can dump an entire mag into them, and they'll still be there, just chillin'.
There's really no downside to calling in a dog if it's available,
and if you're lucky, it might even get a few kills.
B-Tier.
Now, as we all know, I love stabbing people in the neck,
looking them in the eyes, and softly whispering in their ear,
as life slowly drains from them.
Sleep.
I'm sure you do too.
And this tactic is exactly...
that.
Melee only.
In this game, stabbing people is quite fun.
It kinda looks like punching people in the head,
which, as you can see in this clip,
I enjoy very much.
Fucking just stab him in the head!
Just stab him in the head!
Why is it not a thing?!
Ja, ist ja gut, ey.
Pit detection ist halt nicht so die Stärke in diesem Game.
Just stab him in the head!
For optimal stabbage, I'd recommend running Sundance,
wingsuiting around,
sticking a spawn beacon behind somewhere cheeky,
and attacking people from the rear.
Bam.
Aha, from the rear.
Ah.
So, so.
Ah!
Next, we've got Irish.
Who isn't Irish.
He's a former US Marine,
fighting against the US,
as the Russians.
Ja gut, Story ergibt eh keinen Sinn.
You've got this wall thingy
and this trophy system that can destroy projectiles.
These walls are actually really good,
especially because you can see through them
without getting shot through them.
Story ergibt eh keinen Sinn in dem Spiel.
He's not particularly exciting,
he isn't Irish,
hat ja auch keine.
but he's pretty good.
So wirklich.
B-Tier.
I was born on a Dublin street.
Alter, übertreibend!
Lässt er das absichtlich übersteuern?
Dass es sich zwischendurch schockt, oder wie?
Das Ding ist richtig gut
mit 30mm-Geschützen.
Und die Gatling Gun ist auch gut,
aber 30mm-Geschütz ist...
Ach, Moment.
Moment, sie sind beim Hovercraft gerade.
Ne, genau.
Der hier,
das Auto mit dem 30mm-Geschütz
ist richtig heftig.
Das ist der 30mm-Geschütz.
Jetzt, das Ding ist unglaublich gestoppt.
Das ist so, wie es gemacht werden soll.
Durch die riesigen Sandhüten von Doha
flasst der Scheiß aus allem, was sich bewegt.
Übrigens wisst ihr, was auch merkwürdig ist?
Dass jedes Auto mehr oder weniger die gleichen Attachments hat, ne?
Soll ich dir das mal aufgefallen?
Die meisten Fahrzeuge haben die gleichen Attachments
in Battlefield 2042.
Das ist wirklich etwas, was du für dich selbst erleben musst.
B-Tier.
Gehend nach A-Tier beginnen wir mit dem Hovercraft.
Ja, das Fahrzeug, das jeder und sein Hund
überfordert hat.
Ehrlich gesagt, so weit es geht,
ist es okay.
Es ist ziemlich stark gearmt, hat eine gute Minigun,
ist sehr schnell, ist sehr schwierig zu fahren.
Ich finde das übrigens gut,
dass das Hovercraft die Wände hochfahren kann.
Ich hoffe, das lassen sie drinnen.
Weil, na gut, jetzt ist es egal.
Jetzt hast du keine Objectives mehr obendrauf.
Aber ich finde,
es ist ein Bug, der da bleiben sollte.
Wichtig ist,
dass du nicht mehr so viel Zeit hast,
um dich zu verletzen.
Ja, ich finde das gut.
Können das eigentlich echte Hovercrafts auch?
A-Tier.
Next we've got two characters that share the same niche.
Falck and Angel.
These two are both medic-style characters
that support your teammates.
Falck can heal teammates and revive them to full health
and Angel can give people armor and ammo.
I'd say Angel is a bit better,
but Angel is a bit better.
But then...
Näh, Maria Falck ist eigentlich
eines der besten Specialists im ganzen Game.
Einfach, weil du dich easy schnell selbst heilen kannst.
More or less the same.
Und, und, weil du so komische Setups machen kannst,
wie Ammo-Box mitnehmen,
nahezu unendlich viele Self-Heals,
die auch noch schnell gehen
und Motion-Sensor und sowas.
Das ist, eigentlich ist,
ist die S-Tier,
finde ich.
S-Tier ist drei Specialists aus meiner Sicht.
Sundance,
Webstar
und die.
Hat Angel auch unendlich viele Self-Heals?
Force Champ?
Wo du auf den Boden schießen kannst
und innerhalb von zwei Sekunden wieder voll bist?
Ja, das ist aber was anderes.
Das dauert ja viel zu lang.
Das Gute an der Pistole ist,
dass du auf den Boden schießt und drüber läufst.
Das kannst du mit Angel nicht machen.
Ah, Angel does it again.
Angels Voice Lines at the end of the game
are comically bad.
Ja, Angel does it again.
Hahaha.
Wow.
Good one.
Oh, Mann.
Ja, ist ja gut, Mann, Alter.
Reg dich ab.
Umso lauter, umso lustiger, oder wie?
Boris.
Bo-o-o-ris.
Ge-komm-ret.
Next, we've got Boris.
His whole thing is that he has a sentry gun.
When placed down, it automatically spots enemies
and shoots them.
But this is not the best part.
The best part about the sentry gun
is that it gives you wall hacks.
Once the sentry detects an enemy,
it outlines them in a convenient, angry red color.
Unlike Pike's wallhacking thing.
Wisst ihr, was jetzt rauskommt,
nachdem die Leute ein bisschen das Spiel gespielt haben?
Boris an sich ist gar nicht mal so gut.
Aber wer ist auf die großartige,
oder, sagen wir so,
auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen,
dass 50 Leute
Sentry Guns stellen können?
Das ist einfach broken
und unsinnig.
Es ist so dumm.
Dieses Spiel ist so undurchdacht an so vielen,
vielen Stellen.
Das, das tut richtig weh.
It actually lasts for quite a while.
And in the meantime,
the Sentry can also just shoot them by itself.
Not only is this pretty powerful,
but it's also quite fun.
Why did it blow up?
A tier.
Next, combining tracking grenades
with AA missiles.
Ja.
For those who don't know,
the character Sundance has a grenade belt.
Äh, ich, ich, ich spiel, ich spiel,
aber Softlamp ist auch Poggers in dem Spiel.
Äh, weil die Flares nicht richtig
funktionieren.
Ähm, warum Sundance überhaupt
Anti-Air-Granaten hat,
beziehungsweise eigentlich sind es ja Anti-Fahrzeug-Granaten,
die einfach nur, äh, auch auf, äh,
Chopper an, an, locken können.
Ich hab keine Ahnung,
warum es überhaupt Granaten gibt, die
Anti-Air sind.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, sind die Helis in dem Spiel
eh nicht sonderlich anspruchsvoll
und viel, viel, viel zu OP.
Dadurch, dass die Website auch so offen sind.
Pokémon
Blooper
Neuer Video
Have succes
You see, the grenades are slow
and almost never hit helicopters,
but they do cause the incoming missile alert to be tripped.
Anyone who knows what they're doing in an air vehicle
knows that this instant incoming missile
means it's an Anti-Armor grenade
and they won't flare since it's not gonna hit
and that'll just waste their Flirt.
Now, here's where the mischief comes in.
Throw the Anti-Armor,
Drück dein AA-Missil raus und schießt es sofort auf den Helikopter.
Es gibt nichts, was dem Pilot über mehrere zukünftige Missile zu erzählen,
also mehr oft als nicht, werden sie nicht fliegen und das Missil wird geschlagen.
Nächster Punkt.
Diese Waffe.
Die SVK.
Ich erwartete, dass DICE diese Waffe in Oblivion nerven würde, als das Spiel erst erstellt wurde,
weil es so gut war.
Sie haben es definitiv nerven, aber es ist immer noch sehr mächtig.
Im Grunde genommen kann diese Waffe einen DMR in zwei Schrecken töten.
Alle anderen DMRs in diesem Spiel töten in drei oder mehr,
also eine Zwei-Schrecken-Töte ist ziemlich verrückt.
Nicht zu erwarten, dass ich in diesem Star-Torch der ganze Zeit bin,
wo jeder 60 HP hatte und die Waffe alle einschotten konnte.
Nur verdammt.
A-Tier.
Und letztendlich das Fahrzeug-Ausruf-System.
Viele Male hatte ich das gleiche Problem.
Ich habe ein Objektiv gefangen, habe ein paar Jungs geschossen und alle sind tot.
Nun was?
Ich will nicht so weit nach dem nächsten Objektiv fliegen,
weil es nicht funktioniert.
Also habe ich mein Tablett ausgeworfen und habe es in eine Recon-Tabelle geworfen.
Das System ist ziemlich großartig.
Und er ermöglicht uns etwas extra heißes Zeug,
wie z.B. große Fahrzeuge auf Skyscrapers.
Sehen Sie, dass es noch mehr C-4-Waffen gibt.
Das ist der einzige Weg, wie Sie das jetzt machen können.
A-Tier.
Wir sind fertig mit A-Tier.
Jetzt beginnen die wirklich großartigen Strategien.
Sie können sich erinnern, dass ich in meinem Battlefield-4-Video
erwähnt habe, dass ich die Jette als Batterie-Ram benutze
und den Feind mit unglaublicher Geschwindigkeit zerstöre.
Dieses Objektiv wurde schön in C-Tier befestigt.
Nicht besonders effektiv, aber definitiv ziemlich lustig.
Nun, im Jahr 2042 hat es sich um einen
einfachen Wunsch geändert.
Sie sehen, wenn das Spiel beginnt,
wird jeder gezwungen, in den Helikopter zu spawnen.
Wenn man in einem Fahrzeug ist, wird man in einem Helikopter gespawnt.
Aber wenn man nichts wählt, wird man auf einem Helikopter
als Infanterie eingeladen.
Die meisten Leute finden das ziemlich faszinierend,
aber ich mag es, für einen einzigen Grund.
Diese kleinen Anten, die die Helikopter fallen,
sind unsere Zielgruppe.
Sobald Sie es können, schrauben Sie den Kram ab.
Wenn Sie das Spiel beginnen,
befinden Sie sich mit den Jungen
und schlagen Sie sich in den Helikopter.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was davon übrig geblieben ist im Spiel.
Los geht's!
Hahaha!
In diesem Clip habe ich 13 unsuspektive Ante
mit dieser Demos-Strategie getroffen.
Boah!
Alter!
STI.
Proximity Sensors.
Ja, das Ding ist immer noch okay.
Proximity Sensors? Echt?
Ja, aber nicht für den Advertisement.
Proximity Sensors sind großartig.
Das ist schon mal ein ganz guter Nerf gewesen,
aber nachdem du immer noch so Dinger spielen kannst,
wie Maria Falk mit Ammo-Box,
hast du ja eigentlich fast trotzdem unendlich viele.
Also ich mochte es in Bad Company 2.
Ich habe in Bad Company 2 tatsächlich
das einzige Battlefield, wo ich viel Sniper gespielt habe,
hauptsächlich Sniper gespielt
mit Motion-Sensor.
Und One-Hit-Sniper.
Weil du auf der Xbox 360
so ein krasses Quickscope-Auto-Aim hattest.
Das hattest du auf dem PC nicht,
aber wer das auf der Xbox gespielt hat,
du konntest eigentlich mit jeder Sniper,
wenn du den Gegner in der Mitte hattest
und hast reingezoomt,
hat das Auto geaimt auf den Gegner.
Da hast du SV98 oder sowas genommen,
oder egal welche Sniper,
es ist eigentlich egal.
Hast du genommen, bist reingelaufen,
hast reingezoomt, bam, One-Hit.
Ich hatte da teilweise Runden
irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 76 Kills
oder irgendwie so.
Das war schon richtig krass.
Auf der Xbox.
Mit was war Bad Company 2
auf der Xbox? 12 vs. 12?
16 vs. 16?
Ich glaube 12 vs. 12, ne?
Ja.
Besser. Besser. Ja.
Spiel ich auch am liebsten.
Oh nein. Nein, please!
Please, kein Sustrug
jetzt!
Und für einen guten Grund, weil Grappling-Hooks cool sind.
Es gibt fast unendliche Situationen, in denen es dir einen großen Vorteil geben würde, wenn du über den Gegner gehst.
Und ein Grappling-Hook lässt dir genau das mit Ease machen.
Seine Passiv-Abilität ist auch ziemlich groß.
Höhere Bewegungsgeschwindigkeit, hier ist die normale Geschwindigkeit und hier ist McKay.
Ich kann dir nicht sagen, wie viele Male das mich gerettet hat, weil er so schnell ist.
Der einzige Vorteil von McKay ist, dass seine Geräusche wirklich unangenehm sind.
Ich meine, ich bin nicht so schockiert wie du.
Oh mein Gott, hör auf!
S-Tier.
Komm schon.
Kaspar.
Jetzt, ich weiß, was du denkst.
C5 mit der Drohne und einfach nur in den Gegner reinfliegen.
Das wird er jetzt sagen, weil das ist tatsächlich eines der OP-sten Sachen, die es in dem Spiel gibt.
Du brauchst noch nicht mal einen, der C4 auslöst, du kannst das alleine machen.
Wieder so ein undurchsagter Shit in dem Spiel.
Kaspar?
Really?
He's better than Boris and his entry gun?
Yes.
But it's not immediately obvious why.
Kaspar has two signature abilities.
A dude detection thingy on the bottom...
Die Benahmung, dass das Ding C5 heißt, ist eigentlich schon ein riesen Beispiel für die Kreativität der Leute, die an diesem Spiel gearbeitet haben.
Aktuell gibt es C4.
Also, wie muss C4 in der Zukunft heißen?
C5!
Ich meine, wären die wenigstens lustig gewesen und hätten es C69 genannt oder C420 oder sowas.
Ja?
Dann hätte ich ja noch einen gewissen, der ganze Sache irgendwie einen gewissen Witz, äh, abringen können.
Wie hieß das C4 eigentlich in BF...
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Ja.
RDX Demo Pack.
Hieß das, hieß das Ding.
Dann habe ich das Gosh!
Wenn man kann ein bisschen das System verändern.
Und dann haben wir auch viele Möglichkeiten.
Also, wie findet ihr das Ding, C5?
Ja, das ist einfach bin perfekt.
Ich meine, wir haben nur dieisserweise einen hier, aber das ist schon angeboten, oder?
Okay.
Und das ist auch einfach das Problem.
Ja.
Ichенных dieses Ding.
Wir haben uns nur ein wenig gewollt.
Wir haben das Ding einfach überlebt.
Doch, doch, doch, doch.
Dass Dice irgendwas patcht, da kann man wahrscheinlich lang drauf werden.
Rekt, Alter!
Warum hat, was ist eigentlich der Sinn bei diesem Sniper-Ding, dass es so nen, so nen,
so nen Ring drumherum hat?
Zum Tragen.
So cool.
Sollte, sollte der Griff zum Tragen nicht eher in der Mitte sein, wo man quasi Balanced
hat, links und rechts Gewicht, weil wenn das vorne ist, dann hängt die Waffe ja runter.
Das müsste doch eigentlich in der Mitte sein, oder?
Das müsste, das müsste hier so sein, der Tragengriff.
Okay, it's a bit of a pain in the ass to use, but old man hitting nasty shots with this
thing.
Yeah, da hat er recht.
No scope.
360, no scope.
Oh man, ich hab doch irgendwo.
Ja.
Nice!
Very fun gun.
If you really wanna go for gold, I'd recommend using the NTW-50 and the Revolver.
The Revolver can one-shot people in the head, and the NTW can one-shot people everywhere else.
S-Tier.
Next.
End screen,
La Revolver,
the final character.
One you've probably been waiting for the entire video.
Sundance.
AKA The Squirrel Woman.
containers let's say i want to get from here to the ship on this garden all i gotta do is wingsuit
here do a bunny hop here game small speed from another bunny hop here and bang i'm on the ship
not to mention she's also got the grenade belt which we talked about earlier scatter which is
pretty good against infantry anti-armor which is quite good against vehicles and emp which is
pretty similar to rouse hack so it's equipping spawn beacons as her is also incredibly powerful
best character now remember how casper is the best thing to use against ground vehicles at least
for now well this tactic is the best thing to use against air vehicles at least for now the soflam
it basically turns your recoilers into a lock-on that kills helicopters in one shot get yourself a
friend who lasers helicopters and the occasional jab in the soflam while you shoot at it with your
rocket launcher the rocket launcher is a one hit against the scout and after the flares so schön
verbuggt sind das software funktioniert gar nicht mehr ah ja okay
it is unbelievably powerful and i don't see it staying in the game much longer
speaking of air vehicles the best air vehicle in the game not the scout helicopter
not the attack helicopter and not the jet the veto good god i love this thing
it's got high speed two miniguns on the side and this the 50 millimeter cannon
fight against just about any opponent with the exception of the air wildcat the 50 millimeter
is so powerful it's insane enemy helicopter no problem enemy jet yeah easy tank piece of cake
and not to mention the two miniguns on the side are also incredibly strong
what a vehicle truly a work of art
which do you think are the most powerful
i'll give you a hint it's not these
it's not the mav not the hovercraft not the wildcat not even the tank
i would argue that the best land vehicle in the entire game is the m5c bolt
that was really crazy but i think they've nerfed it a little bit by now
or i managed to get over 100 i haven't played much these last few weeks just by using it with
the 30 millimeter cannon it's fast easy to drive can run away from the real real super mines in
front of tanks rocket launcher that can track and kill helicopters
come on yes it's got everything i think these clips really speak for themselves
now gentlemen that's the list but i'm not done yet that's right boys it's now time to list
this game's very very large amount of bugs from least to most the bugs so many bugs
my xp doesn't add up correctly i've died and now the camera is over here all of my vehicle loadouts
have been reset now set them up again intense rubber banding hitting the ground so
spawning right in front of people what the why am i sporting
in front of him unable to connect to ea servers no loadout but where are my loadouts all i can
use is the default m5 the boys have dropped persistence error leute persistence error
except for kai and away he goes
tristan has lost all motor function this invisible platform on hourglass smashing into
buildings with the passing through the sand dunes i am horizontally challenged i am vertically
challenged let's get out of this helicopter my knife has hit my helicopter can't turn to the
left let the body persistence error this guy this monster also the persistence error must
have come the game has started but i'm stuck in the map or the heart of the persistence error
is going on here can't revive teammates if they're close to a wall christian is 69.
but very funny falling into the elevator shaft falling through the map swimming here and
flying back into them getting heated into space tristan is driving a tuk tuk and walking around
at the same time i have died and now i can't respawn nick has gone completely invisible
where'd he go and finally if i knife this ladder in the right spot this happens
what
seriously
so fellas that's it behind the scenes
on this channel here another video here new videos coming soon
das kannte ich gar nicht schon gepatcht okay nein das kannte ich wirklich nicht das war mir neu jetzt
das war mir neu leute ich muss mal kurz pinkeln ich bin gleich wieder da so wieder da
das war für eure kanville
so was haben wir da als neues
also hab ich das schon gezeigt also
ощущenĂacker
AbÇwweĄąêđŠ schöne
reflex YouTube Hey Franck
upstairs
Ch engagement
das 2000lm
nich dabei
blah blah blah
debates
elites
plants
warum
Es ist mich
es ist mich
es
Schon in Clownfield
gesehen, den Trailer
Was für ein Ding
Steam
Das sieht aus, als hätten die
Crunker-Leute in Battlefield gemacht
Passt so gut, der Soundtrack wie das Original
Okay
Aha, na gut
Ich weiß nicht
So diese Games, die immer versuchen
ultra funny zu sein
Ich kann der Sache meistens nichts ab
gewinnen, aber
wahrscheinlich ist das
Requirements
16 Kerne, naja, klar
Jahr 2021, kann man auch schon mal ein bisschen
zu lang, was Hardware
angeht
So, also
was kann man uns als nächstes
Backups, you are doing it wrong
Ne, ich glaube nicht, dass ich es wrong do
Okay, der erzählt
uns die übliche Geschichte
dass
wir drei
Backups brauchen, dass es richtig als Backup
durchgeht
Ja, da ist ja auch was dran
Making
was Google
Google
Reduction with Lego
Ah, die Lego-Videos sind immer pock
Okay, der packt jetzt wahrscheinlich 20
20 Zahnräder aneinander
und dann ist es hochgerechnet, dass ich das
irgendwie einmal in
was weiß ich, da kann ich überhaupt keine Zahl
dafür, weiß ich nicht, wie man
das nennt
einmal
einmal in der Zeit, wo ich das
in allen Gogol-Jahren
dreht
10 hoch 100
Also quasi eine 1
mit 101 Nullen, oder wie?
Gott, das reicht
aber noch lange nicht
Da muss aber noch mehr dran
Ja, da kommt noch mehr dran
Da hast du ein bisschen zu tun
Ah, okay, okay
Einfache Zahnränder machen's
Zahnräder machen's nicht mehr, da muss jetzt
die advancede Taktik ran
Ach, das ist eine Uhr?
Pockers
Eine Lego-Uhr
Das haben bestimmt schon viele gemacht, eine
Lego-Uhr zu bauen
Jetzt
Siehste
Die Zahnräder reichen nicht mehr, weil es muss
ein ordentliches Zahnrad hin
Das ist bestimmt so ein super teures
special Lego-Ding, was nur bei
einem Modell dabei war und was bei
irgendeiner Lego-Brick-Börse oder so
wahrscheinlich 300 Euro kostet oder sowas
Also manche Lego-Teile sind ja brutal teuer
Einfach selbst drucken, easy
Easy
Riesenrad
Ja, es sieht wirklich aus wie ein Riesenrad, ne?
Immer noch zu klein
Next
Alles klar
Oh, Five-Hat-Time, Leute
Extrem Five-Hat-Time
Ah, yes
Only Five-Hat will know
Gut, er muss sich auf jeden Fall keinen Gedanken machen,
dass er irgendwie zu wenig Kraft hätte, das zu bewegen
Weil so langsam wie der Rest schon ist
kannst du damit wahrscheinlich sogar ein Auto hochheben
Oder ein Bus oder so
Es wackelt ein bisschen
Richtig Koggers
Oh, jetzt kommt noch mehr Five-Hat-Zeug
Warum hat man so viel Langeweile, wenn man YouTube-Videos
mit Lego-Dingern macht?
Dann verdient man sogar Geld damit
Okay, jetzt hat er keinen Bock mehr auf Spiränzchen
Jetzt macht er einfach eine riesig lange Kette mit Zahnrädern
Mehr Koggers
Ja, macht er tatsächlich
Das alles so mit einem kleinen Motor
Ja, das ist ja der Vorteil an solchen
Übersetzungen
Du kannst das theoretisch mit quasi allem antreiben
Und es reicht
Weg durch Zeit
Oh, jetzt wird es aber nochmal richtig advanced
Also
Das stimmt tatsächlich
Also in Wirklichkeit praktisch funktionieren wird es wahrscheinlich nicht
Weil bis das hinten sich gedreht hat
ist das vordere wahrscheinlich schon das Plastik auseinander gefetzt
So ein rein theoretisches Konstrukt hier
Jetzt kommt noch die Kette an den Start
Alles klar
Ja, das ist einfach der Lego-Flex
Der zeigt, wie viele Lego-Teile er hat
Wie viele ausgefallene Lego-Teile er besitzt
Die Frage ist jetzt, sind das Lego-Originalteile
Oder sind da auch irgendwelche China-Chinesen-Dinger dabei?
Gibt es da mittlerweile genug?
Ne, das darf man Lego nennen
Das ist ja auch wirklich Lego
Soll mich verklagen
Wobei, mal Lego weiß man nie
Woher du das wissen willst denn?
Weil das einen Titel geschrieben hat
Obviously
Wie wir wissen, alles was in YouTube-Titeln steht, stimmt
Sagt mir einen YouTube-Titel, der mal je falsch gewesen ist
Fake News, gibt's nicht
Odin persönlich dreht sich im Kreis
Tja, ich glaube, er wird nicht filmen können, wie der sich rumdreht
Das dauert zu lang
Wahrscheinlich
Was weiß ich, wie lang das dauert, bis der sich rumdreht
Wahrscheinlich älter, als das Universum alt ist
Das Universum ist ja irgendwie um die 14 Milliarden Jahre alt, aktuell
Wahrscheinlich braucht es länger
Als das Universum schon da ist
Ah ja, okay, ja
Boah, diese Action
Tja
Und es passiert nichts, wer hätte das gedacht?
Das rotiert noch, wenn es die Erde und unser Sonnensystem nicht mehr gibt
Ernst gemeinte Frage
Kann man überhaupt genügend Energie aufbringen um den Motor
Du kannst bestimmt genügend Energie aufbringen
Aber die Frage ist, ob du die Energie, wie du die speicherst
Ist glaube ich eher das Problem
Weil du musst es ja auch noch laufen lassen
Zu Zeiten, wenn die Erde nicht mehr existiert
Ja
Das Zahnrad am Anfang ist ja wahrscheinlich schon nach einem halben Jahr total ausgefranst
Also es ist jetzt hier nur ein theoretisches Konstrukt
Aber eine coole Idee ist es
Gut
Jaja, ganz bestimmt
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid
Jetzt haben wir den Durchblick
Wo wir gerade dabei sind
Passend dazu, wir haben doch gerade gesagt
Das Universum ist 14 Milliarden Jahre alt
Da können wir uns jetzt noch das Video angucken von
Kurz gesagt
Warum wir nicht nach Aliens suchen sollten
Lass mich raten, weil uns die Aliens
Fertig machen
Würden
Oder was auch immer
Gucken wir uns das mal an, der macht immer gute Videos
Das Universum ist unglaublich groß
Und mit Billiarden bewohnbaren Planeten
Das stimmt
Wirkt es anscheinend unendliches Potential für Leben
Eine technisch fortgeschrittene Zivilisation
Die die Sterne bereist
Könnte unsere Galaxie selbst mit nur 0,1% Lichtgeschwindigkeit
In etwa 100 Millionen Jahren besiedeln
Ja der Sprecher ist auch richtig pock
Aber kennt ihr dieses
Wie soll man das nennen
Wahrscheinlich ist es eher ein Gedankenexperiment
Warum das Universum nicht unendlich sein kann
Also wenn es unendlich
Wenn das Universum unendlich groß wäre
Und es quasi unendlich viele
Sternen, Sonnensysteme
Galaxien und sowas gebe
Dann wäre es nachts am Himmel ja nicht dunkel
Sondern hell
Weil an jeder beliebigen Stelle
Quasi an jedem beliebigen Pixel
Müsste ja dann
Wenn es unendlich viel gibt
Was dann so kommt
Müsste irgendwo an irgendeiner Stelle
Egal wie weit entfernt
Irgendwo eine Sonne sein
Wobei das natürlich
Auch nicht mit den aktuellen Sachen hinkommt
So von wegen Universum dehnt sich aus
Licht von quasi
Uns nie erreichen kann
Weil sie schneller ausdehnt
Aber von der Überlegung her finde ich es eigentlich ganz nice
Wie soll das unendlich groß sein
Ich glaube das ist eine Frage
Die kann dir niemand wirklich
Du hast aber einen großen Vorteil
Wenn du sagst das Universum ist unendlich groß
Du musst dir nicht überlegen
Was außerhalb des Universums sein könnte
Weil wenn es unendlich groß ist
Dann gibt es nichts außen drum
Okay weiter
Was gar nicht zu lang ist bedenkt man die Milliarden Jahre
Die die Milchstraße schon alt ist
Jede Raumfahrt Zivilisation sollte sich
Theoretisch also ziemlich schnell
Über weite Teile der Galaxie ausbreiten
Aber davon ist nichts zu sehen
Wir machen erstmal den Planet kaputt
Auf dem wir leben
Und dann gucken wir weiter
Nichts zu hören
Das Universum scheint leer zu sein
Niemand außer uns
Das ist das Fermi Paradoxon
Das wir bereits in anderen Videos beschrieben haben
Ein anscheinend leeres Universum
Ein Dilemma
Wir wollen unbedingt wissen
Ob wir wirklich allein sind in der Milchstraße
Wollen uns bemerkbar machen
Uns jedem zu erkennen geben
Der vielleicht da draußen ist
Aber genau das könnte das letzte sein
Was wir jemals tun werden
Denn vielleicht ist das Universum gar nicht leer
Vielleicht gibt es ganz viele Zivilisationen
Die sich aber alle vor einander verstecken
Vielleicht wurden alle
Die sich je bemerkbar gemacht haben
Lautlos eliminiert
Das Paradoxon ist die sogenannte
Dunkler Wald Theorie
Das Leben des Jägers
Der Jäger erwacht in seinem Versteck
Bevor er sich regt
Lauscht er auf verdächtige Geräusche
Im dichten Unterholz
Eine weitere Nacht
Der Wald ist dunkel und neblig
Der Jäger überlegt
Nach anderen zu rufen
Um seiner Einsamkeit ein Ende zu machen
Aber im letzten Moment zögert er
Was wenn sie so sind
Wie er
Alle Lebewesen wollen überleben
Ressourcen sichern
Und sie vermehren
Im Weg stehen ihnen dabei
Vor allem andere Lebewesen
Mit dem gleichen Ziel
Bei einem Wettkampf zwischen den Arten
Siegt stets diejenige
Mit den vorteilhafteren Eigenschaften
Unsere Vorfahren waren erfinderisch
Und kompetitiv
Wollten sich ausbreiten
Und habgierig Ressourcen ergattern
Deshalb gewannen sie den Kampf um unseren Planeten
Und haben die meisten anderen Tiere
So hilflos ausgeliefert
Dass wir jeden Tag einfach so nebenbei
Etwa 12 Arten auslöschen
Echt?
Aber Menschen sind nicht bloß Individuen
Wir haben Kulturen geschaffen
Die ebenfalls miteinander konkurrieren
Kompetitive, expansive Kulturen
Breiten sich schneller und weiter aus
Und vermischen sich mit anderen Kulturen
Unterdrücken oder zerstören sie
Ein Blick in die Geschichte verrät
Wir sind gefährlich
Nicht nur für andere sondern auch für uns
Also da muss ich nur mal auf Twitter gucken
Dass ich weiß, dass wir gefährlich sind
Unsere menschliche Natur hat uns
Jede Ecke des Planeten erobert
Und schon bald werden wir uns die Sterne vornehmen
Um unseren Lebensraum weiter auszudehnen
Aber auch um noch mehr
Ressourcen zu sichern
Und dann stoßen wir vielleicht auf andere
Die genau das gleiche vorhaben
Mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit
Findet dieser Überlebenskampf
Auch auf anderen weit entfernten Planeten statt
Es ist also nur logisch davon auszugehen
Dass eine außerirdische Zivilisation
Die ihren eigenen Planeten so dominiert
Wie wir die Erde
Uns in vielerlei Hinsicht ähnlich ist
Ist sie das aber tatsächlich
Könnte sie genauso gefährlich sein
Wie wir
Die Konsequenz
Ganz allein
Schleicht der Jäger durchs Unterholz
Vielleicht gibt es andere wie ihn
Er kann aber nicht wissen
Was sie vorhaben
Ob sie gefährlich sind oder nicht
Der Jäger weiß nur
Dass er für sein eigenes Überleben töten würde
Also muss er davon ausgehen
Dass andere das auch täten
Und sollte er auf einen anderen Jäger treffen
Könnte es sein
Dass nur derjenige überlebt
Der zuerst schießt
Einfach Rage quitten
Das alles heißt aber nicht
Dass Konflikte unvermeidlich sind
Bis jetzt hat uns der Fortschritt
Eher friedlicher als gewalttätiger werden lassen
Vielleicht gilt auch für andere Zivilisationen
Dass Fortschritt mit der Zeit
Eher Frieden anstatt Gewalt bedeutet
Außerdem könnte es unter verschiedenen
Außerirdischen Zivilisationen
Von sanft und friedlich
Bis böse und kriegerisch
Alles mögliche geben
Unser existenzielles Problem ist
Dass wir nicht wissen können
Ob andere die wir im All antreffen
Friedlich oder kriegerisch sind
Oder was sie wirklich vorhaben
Genauso verstehen oder vertrauen sie
Ich glaube ich stelle es mir unglaublich schwierig vor
Sollen wir wirklich mal jemanden treffen
Dass wir mit denen kommunizieren können
Was habt ihr vor
Vielleicht auch uns nicht
Selbst wenn wir versichern
Dass wir in friedliche Absicht kommen
Und noch was
Also der Kokona Weg ist natürlich erstmal
Ganz klar
Man schießt die erstmal in Grund und Boden
Und fragt sie danach
Was habt ihr eigentlich vor
Das wäre der logische
Weg dahinter
Eine andere Zivilisation entdecken
Und sie uns
Eine jahrelange Verzögerung
In der Kommunikation
Verunsichert würden sich beide Seiten fragen
Ob es nicht der beste Zug wäre
Einfach anzugreifen
Denn auch das ist ein ernstzunehmender Aspekt
Plötzlicher technologischer Fortschritt
Und der Vorteil zuerst zu schießen
Wir kennen die Grenzen
Der Technologie nicht
Aber wir wissen was für eine große Rolle
Technologischer Fortschritt im Krieg spielt
Wenige hundert oder tausend Jahre Unterschied
In der Entwicklung
Können einem Konflikt
Einen sicheren Ausgang
In ein einseitiges Massaker verwandeln
Das ist kein Problem
Wir haben genug patriotische Kokonas
Im Weltall mit dabei
Das hat man bei Independence Day gesehen
Die regeln das schon
Ist egal ob die technologisch zurück
Oder sonst wie
Fuck yeah
Das wird einfach alles ausgelöscht
Freedom
Die Legionen Cäsars hätten gegen Napoleons Heer
Mit seinen Kanonen und Musketen
Keine Chance
Sie hätten in der Zeit des ersten Weltkriegs
Ausgelöscht worden
Und die hätte den heutigen Drohnen
Und Lenkraketen nichts entgegenzusetzen
Unterschiedliche Zivilisationen
Könnten also auch sehr unterschiedlich mächtig sein
Und selbst wenn nicht
Gerieten wir vielleicht schon in der Zeit
Zwischen der Entdeckung einer fremden Zivilisation
Und einem ersten Hallo
Hoffnungslos ins technologische Hintertreffen
Das wäre schon schlimm genug
Aber ein Aspekt von interstellaren Konflikten
Macht es noch schlimmer
Ist der Feind Lichtjahre entfernt
Braucht eine Flotte bis dahin so lange
Dass sie bei der Ankunft vielleicht schon wieder
Völlig veraltet ist
Bei einem Krieg zwischen verschiedenen Zivilisationen
Könnte es also nur darum gehen
Den anderen zu eliminieren
Um eine existenzielle Gefahr
Für die eigene Art aus dem Weg zu räumen
Andere
Die solche Angst vor dir haben
Dass sie lieber sofort angreifen
Unter diesen Voraussetzungen
Kann nur gewinnen
Wer mit solcher Macht und Geschwindigkeit zuschlägt
Dass das Ziel sicher nicht überlebt
Und auch keine Zeit hat
Konter zu geben oder zu entkommen
Und sich später zu rächen
Bei so hohem Risiko
Gibt es keinen Spielraum für Fehler
Gehen wir davon aus
Dass die meisten Zivilisationen auf Planeten leben
Macht sie das ziemlich verwundbar
Es reicht etwas gewaltiges
Auf den Planeten zu schießen
Das mit dem kaputt machen schaffen wir auch selbst
Da brauchen wir keine Aliens für
Die ultimative
Interplanetare Vernichtungswaffe
Ist wahrscheinlich sowas wie ein
Relativistik Kill Vehicle
Eine Rakete
Die mit annähernd Lichtgeschwindigkeit
Auf einem Planeten geschossen wird
Ein Geschoss das so viel wiegt wie ein Mensch
Und mit 95% der Lichtgeschwindigkeit fliegt
Würde beim Aufprall
So viel Energie freisetzen
Wie sämtliche Atomwaffen der Erde
Würdest du ein paar Dutzend davon
Auf eine Zivilisation schießen
Die du auslöschen willst
Wäre der Erfolg ziemlich sicher
Schon ein einziger Treffer würde reichen
Es ist gar keine so absurde Idee
Eine Zivilisation
Wie schwer ist denn der Mensch
Den man da abschießen muss
Ist er eher so wie ich
Oder ist er dünner
Das ist ja nicht
Unwesentlich die Frage
Auf der Kardashov Skala nur etwas
Höher läge als wir
Hätte genug Energie um mehrere
Geschosse auf jeden Planeten abzufeuern
Auf dem sie leben vermutet
Was diese Waffen so fies macht
Ist der riesige Vorteil den ein
Erstschlag hat
Solche Geschosse wären so schnell
Das es quasi unmöglich wäre sich zu
Verteidigen sind sie einmal abgeschossen
Ein Konflikt zwischen fremden
Zivilisationen wäre also womöglich
Keine langwierige Sache
Sondern eher eine kurze Eskalation
Bei der nur einer
Im Zweifelsfall schießen die beide
Gleichzeitig und machen sich gegenseitig platt
Nämlich der der zuerst schießt
Dadurch ist
Jede Zivilisation eine existentielle
Bedrohung für jede andere
Zivilisation
Und wenn das so ist
Gibt es da draußen vielleicht nur zwei Arten
Von Zivilisationen
Stille und Tote
Was sollten wir also tun
Sollten wir uns Sorgen machen
Es ist unwahrscheinlich dass uns bisher jemand
Entdeckt hat
Die Radiosignale die in den letzten 100 Jahren
Die Erde verlassen haben
Sind bisher noch nicht weit gereist
Und schon lange in unlesbares Rauschen zerfallen
Bei unserem technologischen Stand
Bleiben wir versteckt
Wir werden aktiv versuchen
Auf uns aufmerksam zu machen
Und niemand ausgerechnet unser ziemlich
Unscheinbares Sonnensystem im Blick hat
Aber eines Tages werden wir tief
Ins All vordringen
Und uns diese Fragen ernsthaft stellen
Also ich habe ja so meine
Meine Zweifel ob wir es überhaupt so weit schaffen
Wenn wir so weitermachen wie aktuell
Mal gucken
Also was heißt mal gucken
Wir können da nicht mehr gucken
Aber die Chancen stehen ja durchaus
Dass wir es nicht so weit schaffen
Wir wissen nicht ob es da draußen
Noch andere gibt
Oder ob wir allein im Wald sind
Vorerst scheint es die beste Strategie zu sein
Genau hinzuhören
Und selbst wenn wir andere entdecken
Die auf eine Lichtung treten
Und sich dadurch bemerkbar machen
Sollten wir nicht vorschnell antworten
Sondern sie erst einmal ganz genau
Aus dem Unterholz beobachten
Vielleicht sehen wir das alles
Aber auch vollkommen falsch
Und vielleicht wird es
Ein weiterer Überlebenskampf entwickelt
Und vielleicht beschwört unser primitives Gehirn
Deshalb sofort Ängste vor raubtierhaften Aliens herauf
Dass wir so auf das Universum blicken
Könnte auch bedeuten
Dass wir als Art noch nicht erwachsen genug sind
Vielleicht gibt es da draußen
Eine freundliche Gemeinschaft
Von außerirdischen Zivilisationen
Die uns gerne in Empfang nimmt
Wenn wir so weit sind
Ja die haben nur auf Facebook Boomer gewartet
Ganz bestimmt
Die gute Nachricht ist
Stell dir mal vor
Die scannen irgendwie bei uns
Unsere
Elektronischen Signale
Und Übertragungssachen
Gucken sich das an
Und das erste was die finden
Ist irgendwie die Telegram Gruppe
Von Attila Hildmann oder sowas
Also entweder denken sie sich dann
Okay die muss man direkt auslöschen
Oder denken sie sich
Okay wir warten nochmal 500.000 Jahre
Bis zur nächsten Kontaktaufnahme
Oder noch viele andere Dinge
Dass du mit uns lieber
Keinen Kontakt aufnehmen willst
Wir müssen uns nur gut überlegen
Welche Signale wir in die Galaxie
Würden die natürlich bei mir in den Twitch Chat gucken
Dann müssten die
Da müssen wir sofort hin
Wir müssen den Himmel im Auge behalten
Und immer mehr über unsere Galaxie
Unseren Wald erfahren
Denn was auch immer sich in diesem Wald verbirgt
Freunde oder Feinde
Oder vielleicht auch niemand
Wir können es nur durch sorgfältige
Beobachtung herausfinden
Schließlich erreicht der Jäger
Eine Lichtung
Er findet einen gemütlichen Rastplatz
Langsam vertreibt die Sonne
Den wabernden Nebel
Und jetzt wird er aufgefressen
Bewundert der Jäger seine Umgebung
Vor ihm ein anderer Jäger
Vor Schreck erstarrt
Wie er selbst
Fieberhaft geht der Jäger seine Optionen durch
Dann atmet er tief ein
Und trifft
Die beste Option
Jetzt wäre eindeutig
Wir sind uns glaube ich einig
Und easy win
Eine bedeutsame Entscheidung
Vielleicht ist der einzige Weg aus dem dunklen Wald
Gemeinsam
Die Lichtung zu betreten
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid
Im Prinzip auch nicht mehr als vorher
Aber jetzt wissen wir Bescheid
Schau das mal Rickrolled
Oh ne da habe ich keinen Bock drauf jetzt
Das gucken wir nicht das gucken wir auch nicht
My smart backyard
Easy and automated
Okay was was was
Was ist in seinem Hof
Two is binding
Click of four
Gucken wir uns den jetzt an
Wir brauchen mehr Videos warum Battlefield doof ist
Ne das reicht jetzt
Battlefield ist auch so doof
Warum habe ich eigentlich doppelt
Mehr oder weniger den gleichen Kram auf
Keck Wade
So was hat er denn in seinem Garten so tolles
Zeig mal her
Peace and quiet
So to do this I installed a smart light switch
Alter dieses Kokona Haus schon wieder wenn ich das sehe
Wenn die Amis einfach mit ner Säge
Irgendwelche Schalter in die Wand
Schrauben können
Switch to control the porch lights
Hell yeah
Holzhäuser
I only want them on when someone is back there
So I'm using some ring contact sensors
I like these because
While we're gone or late at night
These sensors are used for the alarm
Then when the alarm is not activated
I can use them for automations
So when the backdoor opens in the evening
Ach ihr habt ja eigentlich gesehen ich habe ein neues Emote freigeschaltet
Fand ich richtig
Fand ich richtig nice
Agreege
Habe ich letztens gesehen
In irgendeinem Stream
Agreege
Wir haben eh mittlerweile 30 Milliarden Emotes
Guckt ah ne ich habe hier gar keine
Gar kein FFZ doch hä
Warum wird es mir nicht angezeigt
Wahrscheinlich weil ich das nicht hier aufgemacht habe
Sondern
Okay wir skippen das mal
Er hat Deckenbeleuchtung
Dann hat er noch mehr Deckenbeleuchtung
Noch mehr Deckenbeleuchtung
Oder oder oder
Hä okay
Alter da müssen ja Mücken
Es fuck rumfliegen im Sommer
In dem seinem Garten
Wenn so viel Licht wie der da am Start hat
Plant lights
Warum genau
Warum genau sollte man
Nachts seine
Bäume anleuchten
Ich habe mal
Gelesen dass das
Bäume also dass das
Pflanzen und Insekten
Und Tiere total verwirrt
Wenn
Es nachts nicht richtig dunkel ist
Die Stromrechnung ist egal
Der wohnt in den USA da geht das
Okay was hat er als nächstes
Doggy door lights
The light turns on whenever the door opens at night
Because it's one of the most
Dangerous places around our house
Dangerous
Luna our dog
Leaves so many landmines out here
If you try to take out the trash
And skip turning on the light
You would probably pay for it
There is also a motion sensor in the doggy door
For Luna and it turns on the light
So she can see better at night
Guck mal sogar der Hund geht
Automatisch
Die haben immer so super krass
Korrekt geschnittenen Rasen
Die müssten mal meinen Garten sehen
Und die Tür schließt sich
Nach 10 Minuten von jeder Tür
Ich möchte auch noch ein paar
Solar Motion Lights auf der Seite des Hauses
Aber ich habe es noch nicht
Und ich muss das bald machen
Hier im Hintergrund habe ich
Eine persönliche Wetterstation
Warum braucht man eine Wetterstation
In Arizona
Ist es nicht immer heiß
Es gibt auch einfach Wettervorhersagen
Ja aber wie heiß
Meldet ihr die Haut ab
Es ist sehr einfach zu erstellen
Der Hintergrund hat Solarpanels
Also musst du dich nie um die Wettervorhersage kümmern
Ja aber man könnte einfach die Wettervorhersage verwenden oder
Oder den Wetterbericht verwenden
Anstatt eine eigene Wetterstation hinzustellen
Du hast viele Klauen
Für einen langen Zeitraum
Die Wetterstation ist ziemlich klug
Und wird temporär
Einige Wetterintensiv-Sensoren
Um die Batterie zu verlängern
Sehr cool
Ich habe es auf einem wirklich starken PVC montiert
Es war wirklich lustig zu haben
Ich hoffe für ihn das läuft nicht mit Lock4J
Ja
Ich arbeite gerade mit SmartThings
Aber Tempus sagt
Es ist sehr einfach zu erstellen
Da man es nicht mit Wasser benötigen muss
Aber ich mag es
Das ist Rasen den man nicht gießen muss
Ich mag es
Und wir haben dieses Half Dome Plaything
Und meine Kinder lieben es
Wir haben es auf Amazon bekommen
Und es dauerte lange
Stimmt AliExpress Rasen
Auch wenn wir Turf haben
Das ist doch Werbung oder?
Ist das Werbung?
Sack
Ne, anscheinend nicht
Es ist auch nicht schwierig zu installieren
Und wenn du es draußen installieren musst
Du brauchst nur ein Outdoor Kabel
Auf dem Channel
Und das ist es
Das war es
Bis zum nächsten Mal
Tschüss
So
Ist das echtes Feuer oder ist das Fake-Feuer?
Ah, das ist Gas.
Das sieht nur aus wie Feuer mit Kohle.
Das ist Fake, weil ich wollte gerade sagen,
das sieht nicht aus wie ein Feuer mit Kohle.
Das ist echtes Feuer,
aber kein richtig echtes Lagerfeuer dann.
Das ist auch so ein typisches Ami-Ding, oder?
Das ist auch so ein typisches Ami-Ding.
Neben der Tür hat er noch seinen Elektroschocker liegen.
Man könnte einfach ein Feuerzeug nehmen oder irgendwas,
aber das...
An Lock4J was mit Lock4Net zu tun? Nö.
Lock4Net ist die .NET-Geschichte.
Das ist auch Apache,
aber das Problem ist ja nicht mal Lock4J an sich.
Wenn man das...
Wenn man das portiert in eine andere Programmiersprache,
das Problem ist ja, dass Lock4J Java-Klassen nachlädt
mit irgendeiner internen Nachlademechanik.
Und selbst wenn du Lock4J portierst auf eine andere Sprache,
wird das nichts bringen.
Ich finde auch nicht...
Chat, gebe ich euch recht?
Ich finde nicht, dass das sonderlich gemütlich aussieht.
Das sieht aus wie eine Battlefield-Map.
In klein, oder?
Das könnte eine Battlefield-Map sein.
Sowohl von der Beleuchtung her,
als auch so eine Battlefield-2042-Map ist das.
Halt in klein.
Es ist halt nichts drauf.
Es ist hier irgendwie so ein Gebäude.
Es hat keinerlei Deckung. Es ist flach.
Eine Sache, die ich hier nicht in die Welt kommen konnte,
sind die Tesla-Solarpanel und Powerwalls.
Und ich bin gespannt, wie ich sie in einem kommenden Video verwenden kann.
Also macht sicher, dass ihr auf dem Kanal folgt.
Danke fürs Zuschauen.
Ja, es ist Kokona-Zeit.
So, und der geht jetzt noch.
Der geht jetzt noch.
Two is binding.
...and Deadbolt, that I've put in a demo block.
And anyone with experience picking dimple locks
probably won't have too much trouble opening it up.
Ah, yes.
That said, it does have a couple of really nice features
and the build quality is off the charts.
I've never seen anything like it,
even in locks five times the price.
Now, the most noteworthy feature
is that you don't need a key to lock this from the outside.
After all, the name is EZ-Lock.
You just turn that knob.
Easy.
If you're concerned about a passer-by locking it,
you can disable that function
by flipping that switch on the inside.
Then it no longer works.
And interestingly,
if you flip that same switch
while the Deadbolt is extended,
you can no longer use the key
to open it from the outside.
Ah, yes.
Essentially, it's a built-in
Night Latch.
So, let's assume,
this is not latched from the inside
and see what it takes to pick it open.
Then I'll take it apart
and show you what impressed me so much
about the build quality.
I'm going to use this Z-Bar
as a turning tool
and a multi-pick dimple flag.
Click out of one.
Might have gotten something on two.
Click out of three.
Click out of four.
Nothing on five or six.
Back to the beginning.
Nothing on one.
Click out of two.
Nice one.
Nothing on three, four, five, six is binding.
Click there.
And we've got this open.
Okay, let's take this apart.
We start by removing three screws
that are around the bezel on the inside.
That allows us to remove the thumb turn assembly
from the inside.
And notably,
this thing spins,
very freely.
And that's because there's actually a ball bearing inside.
Let's take this apart a little bit more
and I'll show you.
Ich würde das wahrscheinlich nicht mal zusammenkriegen,
wobei, das ist doch übersichtlich jetzt.
That all of the castings in here
are not, as you would expect,
a cheap zinc alloy.
These are all stainless steel castings,
which are considerably more expensive.
And here we go.
After going through one, two,
three, four stainless steel castings,
we have the first of the ball bearings inside of this.
Now we can start removing the rest of the lock from the door.
That's done by taking two more screws out.
This backer plate is made out of a nice thick stainless steel.
And notably, all throughout this lock,
there are little arrows that say up and down
that make it really hard to install this in correctly.
Nice little touch.
Das Log4J-Video von LiveOverflow, wie lang ist das?
Warum baut er das jetzt eigentlich auseinander?
Was ist denn jetzt der Punkt dabei?
Ah, er zeigt uns das eigentliche Schloss.
17 Minuten, nee, das ist zu lang.
Okay, keine Ahnung, warum ich mir das jetzt angeguckt habe,
die erste Hälfte hat gereicht.
Das ist Log4J-LiveOverflow.
Moment, das soll es vielleicht auch noch...
Das da, 17 Minuten, das ist ja busy zu lang jetzt.
Das ist ein bisschen zu lang.
Die Java-Brains erklären, wie Log4J funktioniert.
Ach, da sind wir bei den Richtigen.
Wenn die Java-Brains das erklären, dann versteht man es vielleicht.
Java-Five-Heads, ja.
Angst vor fünfter Welle wächst.
Hä, ich dachte, wir haben gerade schon irgendeine Welle.
Wie viele?
Haben wir jetzt gerade die vierte Welle oder sind wir schon in der fünften Welle?
Ich blick nicht mehr durch.
Ich weiß nur, dass ich am, ich glaube, 12. Februar eine Runde Booster-Impfungen kriege.
Dauerwelle.
Genau.
Wir sind quasi immer am Läden.
Damit.
Aber mehr Homeoffice, das stimmt schon.
Dafür ist es tatsächlich gut.
Eines der Sachen, die wirklich vorteilhaft waren an Corona oder sind an Corona.
Mehr Homeoffice.
Und es setzt sich auch immer mehr durch.
Alter, der Chat wieder richtig...
Die perfekte Welle.
Es wird ja immer schlimmer, Chat.
VogueGuard.
Oh je.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn ich diesen Videotitel schon sehe,
dass das wieder ein ziemlich triggerndes Video ist.
Was?
Battlefield 2 Conquest?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Was?
Es gibt Leute, die Battlefield 2 Liga Competitive...
Ernsthaft?
Das ist kacke.
Warum?
Immer noch am Stadion.
Pornhäuser.
Ja, das ist mittlerweile ziemlich verbreitet.
Eigentlich kann da mehr oder weniger jeder was mit anfangen mittlerweile.
Was ist mit Vogue gemeint?
Es ist auch eine ganz gute Umschreibung, gerade wenn man sagt, die ganzen Twitter-Empörten.
Dann versteht keiner, was man meint.
Wenn man sagt, aber die ganzen Vulkan-Twitter-Empörten, dann weiß jeder, was man meint.
Das ist eigentlich mittlerweile überall mehr oder weniger verbreitet, würde ich sagen.
Du musst bald C++ für die Uni lernen.
Oh, das ist PainsChamp.
C++ ist wirklich nix, wo man Spaß dran hat.
Gestern war wieder...
Eine Anti-Corona-Maßnahmen-Demo oder so in Frankfurt, die aufgelöst werden musste, habe ich gelesen auf Twitter.
Da ging es wohl ein bisschen ab.
Holy C.
Ich weiß, soviel die Forward Declaration C++ gut ist.
Oh, excellent.
Pfeifertime.
Du meinst das vorletzte Mal, was wir letztens im Stream hatten?
Ich weiß schon gar nicht mehr, wie das Ganze ausgeschaut hat.
Moin.
Zehnhundert Sekunden.
Ne, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Leute, ich habe Hunger.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Das hatten wir das letzte Mal.
Ne.
Was?
Das ist doch G-Bait.
Das ist kleiner gleich und nicht Reverse Lambda.
Das ist G-Bait-Frage.
Soll ich doch kleiner gleich.
Huge G-Bait.
Chat, ich gehe jetzt essen.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Macht's gut.
See you.